[MUSIC PLAYING]
GEROVITCH: So I think
everybody is here,
so I thought maybe
we could start.
My name is Slava Gerovitch.
And my email is on the
board, which conveniently
has my first name on it.
Professor David
[? Mandel, ?] who
is the principal investigator on
this project, is speaking today
on the National Public Radio
on Science Friday program.
So I'm not sure
if he'll be here.
[? Sandy ?] [? Brown ?] who
is a research assistant,
and who has been in
contact with all of you,
is currently in New Zealand.
And he couldn't make
it back because of
the recent tragic events.
So I think these
events kind of make
us think that maybe
we should appreciate
every day of our
lives that we have,
and try to do as much
work as we can today.
I will say a few words about
the overall project for the sake
of Jim Miller and [? Eric ?]
[? Taylor, ?] who were not here
at the first meeting.
The project is called History
of Recent Science and Technology
on the Web, and its goal is
to develop some tools that
would enable veteran scientists
and engineers to participate
in writing the history of
their particular disciplines
or projects.
So our role as historians
here is just be your helpers,
to offer you some tools
and to listen to you what
you would like to have in
terms of support and logistics
that would allow you to
contribute to writing history.
There are different formats
for using the web in this way.
Some people prefer using
web forums or email
lists, things like that.
David [? Mandel ?]
has suggested that we
would have these live
meetings, where people would
exchange their
memories and discuss
some of the historical issues.
Then we would have these
meetings transcribed
and put transcripts on the
web, where everybody could
read them and comment on them.
We also are planning to put-- or
actually are already doing it--
to put some archival
documents up
on the web, where
you could read it
and, again, you
could write comments
on particular documents,
on parts of it, which
will also be posted on the web.
So people after that
could come and see
your comments and the
original document,
and maybe write
some other comments.
So these are the kind of things
that we're thinking about.
If you would think that some
other forms, like a discussion
list, would be
helpful, please let us
know, and we'll try that.
I don't know if anybody of you
took a look at the website,
which is hrst.mit.edu.
And it stands for history of
recent science and technology.
Doesn't have any www.
So this is the
overall project, which
includes five
subprojects, one of which
is Apollo guidance computer, one
is molecular evolution theory,
one is bioinformatics,
and a couple of others.
In different fields, people
try different approaches.
We'll see what
works in our case.
So far, we've had one
meeting last month.
And we already have
a transcript of it.
And as far as I know, it's
been circulated somewhat,
and people wrote
some corrections.
And we are planning to
put it up on the web
shortly, within the
next couple of weeks,
where you will all be able
to see it and comment on it.
I should mention
that this website
is kind of working tool.
So it has two layers on it.
One is public, what
everybody can see,
and one is a working area
where only members of our group
can see.
And so when you put
your comment on the web,
only members for
our group would be
able to see it at the
moment, so because we
would like to have
some kind of place
where we would be able to
discuss our views freely
and have some debate.
And then we would
decide to what extent
we would open it
up to the public.
So at the first
meeting, we generally--
I'm just saying it for the sake
of Jim Miller and [? Eric ?]
[? Taylor, ?] who
were not there--
we generally had an introduction
when people talk a little bit
about their role in the
development of software
for the Apollo
guidance computer.
And some of the
general topics came up.
What I would like
generally to do
is to focus on a
few important issues
in this project that
really made that project so
salient and significant,
issues that, first of all,
allow that enormous
enterprise to be
accomplished successfully.
So as Fred Martin, I
think, put it last time,
if we had to do this program
today in the manner in which
programs are done today,
I don't think the program
could have ever be done.
I don't think that the
amount of paper generated,
the meetings, the views, the
number of people involved,
I don't think the program
could have ever gotten
off the ground.
So that's a very
interesting comment
that suggests that the way
the project was done back
in the '60s was kind of unique.
And we've tried to
recreate that uniqueness.
And for the reason, your own
reminiscences as participants
are invaluable.
That's something that
documents cannot tell us.
So I would ask you
to bring up as much
as you can these elements
of uniqueness, of something
that distinguish that
particular project
and you work on it
from other things.
If you could compare it
particularly with other things
that you encountered in
other times and other places,
organizations, and to
draw explicit comparisons,
that would help us,
too, to determine
what distinguishing
features that would
be particularly helpful.
Another thing that
we would like to do
is to avoid writing kind
of linear history, when
basically what we often can see
is just a line of decisions.
First there is this, then
that, then this, then that.
[? And then it's ?]
[? success. ?] There are always
some points where different
decisions could be made.
There were debates
when, you know,
there were some roads not taken.
At some places, they had to go
back and take the other road,
and then go back.
So we'd like to recreate that
rather complex road map instead
of just a sequence of
solutions that we eventually
found their way in
the eventual product.
So we'd like to have that sense
of debate, of controversy, what
exactly was the
points of contention
at different points
of the project?
Which design decisions or
organizational decisions
were particularly important
and debated at the time,
so that history
would be alive rather
than a sequence of facts.
A few things that came
up in terms of topics
that we discussed last
time, or the issue
of the degree to which the
automatic and manual systems
must be combined in the
guidance of a spacecraft.
And as far as I can
see in this discussion,
mostly the issue of trust in the
electronic equipment came up.
And the astronauts
didn't really trust it.
So the automatic side had
to be justified somehow.
While in the Soviet
program, curiously--
and I should mention that I am
actually working on the Russian
side of this story--
in the Soviet program, the
issue was to what extent
we can trust the humans,
the opposite issue.
So somehow, the Soviets
had a greater belief
in automatic systems,
in their reliability,
and they thought that the
humans were the weakest link.
So I'd like to
kind of frame that
issue a little bit
around this question.
Maybe these issues came up
in your project, as well,
but you simply
didn't mention it.
So that would be interesting.
Another thing is man-machine
interface, to what extent
the astronauts had an input into
the way they wanted to interact
with the computer,
to what extent
computer designers
had their say.
The role of warning
systems, to what extent
computer was allowed
to let the astronaut
knows that something
that astronaut is doing
is not really right.
The issue of memory constraints
and speed constraints
that really put a limit on
these kind of backup and warning
systems.
Also, series of
implementation meetings
was mentioned in the issue
of disciplining the software
program, introducing
all sorts of measures
that kind of
streamlined that process
and made it manageable from
the NASA point of view.
And I would like to--
maybe if you could
say a few words
about the way that was
done, how it was accepted,
what consequence did it have,
and a little bit more detail
on that.
And lastly, the question of
openness of the whole project.
Again, there is a
startling contrast
with the Soviet program,
which, as you know,
was all classified and run
under the military umbrella,
while the Apollo
project was open.
And some of the participants
in the last meeting
stressed that it had
a very important role.
And I really want to push
you a little bit on that,
and see whether this
openness actually maybe posed
some problems for you,
in terms of interacting
with military people.
Maybe military
people didn't want
to tell you something because
they knew that your project was
open, or--
I'm just speculating
about that, maybe
it wasn't a problem at all.
So maybe you could say
a few words about that.
So today's meeting, I would
suggest to start by asking Jim
Miller and [? Eric ?]
[? Taylor, ?] who were not here
the first time--
PRESENTER 7: [? I ?] [? was ?]
[? here. ?] [INAUDIBLE] Alex
[INAUDIBLE].
GEROVITCH: Oh, Alex
[INAUDIBLE],, sorry.
To introduce themselves
and to talk a little bit
about your role in the Apollo
guidance computer story.
And then we would
go around the table
and have people talking
about the issues.
Start with Alex?
PRESENTER: OK.
I think I started the--
I joined the lab in '63.
PRESENTER: For the second.
PRESENTER: Hm?
PRESENTER: For the second time.
PRESENTER 5: For
the second time.
Dan was one who winkled
me out of England
to come over at the start
of the Apollo program.
I came as a physics graduate.
I knew nothing about
computers, analog or digital.
I knew nothing
about programming.
PRESENTER: I knew that.
[LAUGHTER]
PRESENTER 5: And one
of my observations
actually has to do with that
because one of the successes
here--
I mean, I know when
Margaret joined,
she didn't know anything about
inertial navigation systems--
I hope I'm not putting
words in your mouth--
and yet, we grew this
knowledge to the extent
that we needed to understand it,
to control the right programs
that control it.
To me, that was always amazing,
that so few people, relatively
inexperienced in the subject
that we were dealing,
they were just smart
people, managed
to acquire enough information
from a vast array of resources
around us in the lab to not be
blocked by a wall of ignorance.
I can't move because
I don't know.
You went and found out.
You talked to people.
And there weren't very
many people that you
needed to do that with.
To me, one of the
strengths of that program
was the few people
that were working.
And we always came to
the conclusion-- and Dan
and I talked about
this in the early days,
that the optimum size of
a software group producing
complicated software like
this was about five or six,
because during some of
the stressful period
where we were really
churning stuff out,
there were little knots of
five or six people that really
put the foundations to this.
One of my roles when I began to
feel my way around that I can
remember-- and my memory is
really starting to come apart
at the edges--
was to integrate
some of these areas.
There was a launch area,
there was a reentry area
[? on the dam, ?] there was
a powered flight area, who
were investigating some
of the technical problems
in these various areas.
I had to stick these together
in order to achieve our first
guided flight, which
I still have pictures
and [? stuff of ?] which we
knew as Apollo [? 202 ?] is
to manufacture the glue and just
make stuff up that integrated
the astronauts' actions, the
powered flight equations,
track the launch, which
we didn't control.
So when the time we took
over, we knew where we were
and how fast we were going
[INAUDIBLE] then we took over.
The midcourse stuff, which was
a whole other ball game, which
I knew absolute nothing of.
And even at the
end of the program,
I really didn't
understand it very well.
So my role was to knit some
of these pieces together.
And my memory is dim, but it was
a heck of a lot of hard work.
Long hours.
Stuff didn't work.
Stuff we made up as we
went along didn't work.
But in the end, it all did work.
If I remember rightly,
that first flight
landed remarkably close to
its objective in the Pacific.
PRESENTER: Being
late late for lunch,
because I wouldn't
let you go you
when you were dying of hunger.
You remember a few
of those, right?
PRESENTER 5: I can ramble
on, but I think to me
the amazing thing about
this, looking back,
was the quality of the people,
the [INAUDIBLE] of the people,
the immense support that you
got from all the resources
that were arrayed around you.
The openness, I guess, is what
you were referring to before.
We ourselves, at least
that's what I felt,
were the only blocks,
because of ignorance.
But we overcame that as we went
along, and we made it work.
I'll just shut up at that point.
I'd like to hear what some of
the other people [INAUDIBLE]..
PRESENTER: You'll
get another chance.
GEROVITCH: All right.
[? Jim? ?]
PRESENTER 1: Not sure
exactly how much of what
to cover, but let me cover
some things briefly about how
I got there and what I did.
I evaded the draft
during the Korean War
by going off to graduate
school and staying in college.
Got a master's degree in
electrical engineering.
And that was as long as I could
postpone being in the service.
And I entered the service
in 1956, the Air Force,
and was assigned to a place
called Cape "Cana-vare-al,"
or something I had
never heard of.
John [? Daley, ?] who
read the news on TV,
hadn't heard of it either, and
that's how he pronounced it.
But within a week or
two of being there,
I was out at the
Cape, and watched
the Redstone launched at night.
And I was completely hooked
into the idea of rocketry
and guiding the things.
And I stayed in the
service a couple of years,
and came up to MIT to get
a doctorate in program--
Doc Draper-- called
instrumentation,
which was a combination
of academic disciplines,
multi-departmental.
I started writing code for
computers in '57 or something.
We had a digital
computer down there.
And eventually, I got
into programming it
for whatever reason.
And writing my
doctoral thesis, I
got into both
celestial mechanics--
because I wrote on guidance of a
one-pound thrust rocket vehicle
from Earth orbit to lunar orbit.
1,000-pound vehicle with a
one-pound engine, if I recall.
It takes a long time
to build up the energy
you need to get up to the moon.
But in the process,
I learned a lot
about celestial mechanics
and trajectories,
and about writing
code for computers.
And I really have to say
that the computer part of it
appealed to me more than
any of the other parts,
although I liked
celestial mechanics.
But when I finished my
work, Doc Draper had,
through his
incredible influence,
landed a sole-source
contract at the laboratory--
instrumentation lab,
where I was based--
to do the Apollo guidance
system in late '61.
And with Bob [? Stern, ?] Dick
[? Batten, ?] and Hal Laning,
we were a group of what I think
was called Advanced Guidance
or something to work
the Apollo problem.
There were other people
in the [? Polaris ?] side
that were busy, as well.
But we started without
really having any contact
with those folks.
I worked on
trajectories and trying
to figure out abort
trajectories and so forth.
But pretty soon--
maybe that was later,
but Hal Laning had written an
executive and an interpreter
for a computer, which
was being proposed
to be the onboard
computer for Apollo, which
was a computer that had
originally been intended
to fly to Mars and
take one photograph,
and come back and
drop it somewhere
where it could be retrieved.
It never happened,
but that computer,
which was a 15-bit
computer, of all things,
with three bits for op code
and 12 bits for address,
was very nicely designed.
It had eight op codes and
4K of memory, of which I
think 500 words were erasable.
The rest was fixed memory.
These folks know more
about that than I do.
But Hal had written this
executive that dispatched tasks
on a priority basis,
and an interpreter,
which was something I'd never
even thought of or heard of.
Hal was probably not the first
to do that, but a real pioneer
in a lot of ways.
But he had written
its code, and I
started reading it
and trying to make it
better, which was difficult.
But it occurred to me that
one of the things that we
were going to need is something
that simulated that computer.
Because we didn't have a
computer to run, and if we had,
it wouldn't have been designed
for debugging and so forth.
So I got, eventually, into
the game of writing a computer
simulator for the Apollo--
for what we called
then the Mars computer.
And that developed,
over time-- and I
sort of skip around a
lot-- but over time,
into a full simulation of the
spacecraft, [? the ?] guidance
computer, all of the hardware
that interacted directly
with the computer, or that
controlled the spacecraft,
and even with the crew,
including where the fixed
stars were, and all the sextant
operations and so forth.
And ended up in the
library developing
a star catalog, which
as far as I know,
was the one that
went to the moon.
Well, I don't really know.
I lost track of it.
But they don't change very fast,
so it probably stayed the same.
And the group developed into, I
don't know, half a dozen people
or so on different aspects
of writing the simulation.
And we were racing to get it
ready in time for Alex's Tool
[? Two ?] software.
And I say Alex's because
he was in charge of it,
and bore the brunt
of all the stress.
Other folks just
took life easy, and--
PRESENTER 6: Like Margaret.
PRESENTER 1: Margaret
and Dan, and [INAUDIBLE]..
But trying to keep up with their
needs to do the simulation.
We had, at that time, moved
from 650 powerhouse [? of the ?]
instrumentation lab up
to a Honeywell machine,
which was designed to do
insurance programming,
I think, and had
lots of tape drives.
And fun machine, but
wasn't quite fast enough,
so we eventually
got a faster one,
and then we moved
onto IBM machines.
PRESENTER 5: Is that the
one with [INAUDIBLE] on it?
[INAUDIBLE]
PRESENTER 1: I remember one day,
we had two [? 370 ?] 75's, just
about the world's fastest
commercially-available
machines, other than
maybe some other--
[? I'd seen ?] more
[? crazy ?] machines.
And we had fixed
it up so each one
had two big [? 23 ?] 14 arrays.
23 [? 14 ?] was
a big disk drive,
which was about the
footprint of this table.
It had eight
multi-platter disks in it.
Nine, actually, because one
would fail or something.
I guess it was for
loading up another on one
while the other
ones were in use.
And as I recall,
we had two of those
connected to each machine.
And because of cable
restrictions and distance
of the machines,
we had a fifth one
that was halfway between
the two machines,
with a cable running from
each, so we had a shared disk.
And I remember standing
there thinking,
we have a gigabyte of storage
on this machine-- well, almost--
between these machines.
And I thought that was--
I mean, it was, at the time,
absolutely mind-boggling.
Not nearly as mind-boggling
as what's happened since then.
[LAUGHTER]
PRESENTER: You should point out,
a megabyte on the 75 cost about
$1 million.
[INAUDIBLE]
PRESENTER 1: Well, the
machine that I ordered--
the 75 that I initially ordered
had 1/2 a megabyte of memory.
And little did I know--
and it [? had ?] four 23
[? 11's ?] because the 23
[? 14's ?] weren't available.
I've forgotten how
small the 23 11's were.
PRESENTER 5: I [? think ?]
the 28 megabytes.
PRESENTER 1: They were small.
PRESENTER 5: Yeah.
PRESENTER 1: And the
operating system used up,
I think, all of the space,
and all of the memory,
leaving no space
for anything else.
But memory was so expensive.
We just-- well, we had to buy--
we went up to a whole megabyte.
I remember, living in
the Netherlands, bought
a megabyte of memory for
my AT that I had bought.
And rode home from
the electronics store
with a megabyte of memory
in my pocket on my bicycle.
And I thought, gee, things
have really progressed.
Now my 60-gigabyte disk that
I have on my machine at home
fits on my shirt pocket.
Just can't believe
what's happened.
And it is very difficult for
me, having even been there--
and I think for people
who weren't there,
almost impossible--
to imagine the difficulties
that people dealing
with a machine with a 15-bit
word and lots of restrictions
upon expanding it-- even though
the technology was available,
the reliability requirements
prevented much happening
that would take advantage of
what could have been done.
Trying to squeeze
enough software in there
to fly to the moon and
back into what became,
I think, 36 K-words
of fixed memory,
and 1K of erasable memory.
PRESENTER 6: 2K.
PRESENTER 1: 2K, yeah,
and 1K accessible.
Right.
And squeezing that out of 3-bit
op code and 12-bit address
took some funny
shenanigans, which caused
a lot of debugging activity.
But I don't think anybody can
imagine the kinds of problems
that were faced
trying to squeeze
a huge amount of software into
that tiny machine, which really
was small.
After getting the
simulation group going--
and there are lots of
war stories about that,
probably of little interest
to most and known by the folks
here--
I foolishly accepted
the responsibility
of becoming the leader
of the mission program
for the first lunar module.
This was after the Apollo
fire, and long hiatus
of flights during which time
everybody moved to the block
two stuff.
And I remember a
long, long time,
it seemed that Alex was
sweating and working
on the [? 202 ?] software.
The 204 software had never flew.
It was going to fly in that
[INAUDIBLE] which the three
astronauts died on the
[? pad. ?] But I went to Alex,
and I don't know if
Alex remembers this,
but I remember it.
I've told a lot of people.
I said, Alex, I
don't know anything
about the mission software.
I've been doing the
simulation and trajectories,
and I know all that stuff.
Cool.
But I don't know anything
about the mission program.
What do I do?
What did you do?
He says, well, anytime
somebody comes to you
and asks you what they
should do, make something up.
And I said, you're kidding.
He said, absolutely not.
He said, if they come to
ask you, they don't know,
and they know better
than anybody else.
So if they don't know
and you don't know,
you got to make something up.
Well, he was exactly right.
It worked.
You just had to not
get stuck on something.
You just had to
take a path, and not
all of the things that
either us made up,
probably, but certainly
in my case, worked.
But if they didn't work,
you found out about it.
And then somebody would come
back and say, this didn't work.
What should I do you?
And make up something
else different.
And that usually worked
because then you knew.
It was the seat of the
pants a lot of the way.
And that's probably a good
place for me to shut up for now.
[INAUDIBLE]
PRESENTER: [INAUDIBLE]
about 9:15.
[INAUDIBLE]
PRESENTER 2: Well, I got
involved in the Apollo project
by way of a backdoor.
I was working for
Raytheon, and attached
to the instrumentation
lab on the Polaris project
as a resident.
And shortly after that
petered out a little bit,
I became reattached as a
resident on the Apollo program
in the computer group.
And when I-- just putting
things in context,
I was all of three
years out of school.
So not what you'd call
really, tremendously
experienced in computer design.
But got into the computer
group and was doing work
with Ramone and Dr. Hopkins,
Dave [? Shanksy ?] to go ahead
with the Morris computer.
And then, shortly
after arriving,
the concept of the
integrated circuit arose.
I remember a meeting in
Elden Hall's office, where
we all gathered around and tried
to determine which direction
the group ought to go as
far as implementing either
with the Morris circuit
technology, the core transistor
logic, or the integrated circuit
approach, and all of the issues
that that was going to raise.
And the decision was made to
go ahead with the integrated
circuit approach.
Of course, none of us knew
what an integrated circuit
was at that time.
But I ended up with
the responsibility
of re-implementing the Morris
design in the integrated
circuit world, and
carried that through.
It's a very interesting
computer design.
Many levels of interrupt.
I remember tech words like
pink, mink, shink, and shank--
[LAUGHTER]
--for, essentially,
instantaneous reaction
to requests from
resolvers and sink rows,
and communication links,
and things like that.
And a multi-structured level of
interrupts and software levels
of hierarchy.
I also remember a
fateful day in 1963,
sitting in the Apollo
computer lab, which
was a big room, and then
a little room behind it.
I was in the little
room behind it
with the first brass board
Apollo computer prototype.
I was debugging it when the
word came that Kennedy was shot.
That was kind of a
real seminal moment.
I think everybody became
particularly re-energized
in making this project work.
And that was my role.
I did a little bit
of programming,
when the design was finished,
to some orbital calculations.
But my role was primarily in
the design of the hardware.
PRESENTER 3: I'd like to add
something to what Herb did,
which was a quote which I think
applies to the business of you
could do this project today.
At the time the Apollo computer
first became available,
there was an internal
need to have something
that could show that it worked.
Not that it did the job, that
this computer was [? alive. ?]
And Herb programmed
the little game,
which would be completely
primitive by today's standards.
But it was a little version
of "Pong," in which the ball
bounced all over the place.
And it was after doing that,
and then all the work that
came after, that Herb--
I heard Herb, when they say,
you can do so much with 4K
and so little with 40.
You know?
You can do so much with five
people and so little with 400
people all trying to
do the same job, which
I think is part of the thing.
And what I think the--
in terms of why the
project can be done,
I think the genius was
in the partitioning
of this project that [? was ?]
based on several things.
One is having a clear goal.
The other having an institution
that was already talented.
[? You ?] can't do that.
You're going to go anywhere.
But then, the fact that the job
was broken up so that people go
work, as to what they did.
And didn't have to constantly
cross-check everything
at every second.
There was plenty
of that to be done.
But I think that
that's probably one
of the [? signature ?]
characteristics
of that project.
I've been in many projects since
then-- and everybody here has,
too-- and I think that those
projects that fail almost
always had enormous
bureaucracies of cross-checking
that just didn't seem--
the partitioning was wrong.
GEROVITCH: Do you think
the right partitioning
was achieved by
intuition, or did
that idea come from somewhere?
PRESENTER 3: Well, generally,
somebody's-- there's got to be
a combination of political and
technical architecting done.
I don't know if
it's any one person.
But I think the lab had--
first of all, the lab was
divided by stovepipes.
So there was the gyro group, the
[? Herschel ?] platform group.
Then there were the single
commissionings, and then
the optics group.
And then the
computer group, which
was kind of a foreign
object in the lab,
as I recall, for many years.
But so that partitioning by
discipline already existed.
But even within that,
I think once the job
was done that there
was going to be
a mid-term guidance
and a booster guidance,
and a reentry.
And there's going
to be an abort.
All these things
were partitioned--
[? it's ?] probably Davie
[? Hoag ?] was the person who
just thought that this was
the way the world should be.
So I think that it requires
a [? architecting ?]
visionary on that.
PRESENTER 1: Our
space life consists
of a lot of periods of
thrust and activity,
followed by long
periods of just tracking
where you are flying to.
And so some of the partitioning
just came from the separation
by periods of inactive flight.
GEROVITCH: Sure, sure.
PRESENTER 4: You want us to--
are you through over there?
Should we all start?
PRESENTER: Sure.
Now it's all yours.
PRESENTER 4: Well, I
have, I think, two things.
One, the overall
speed, I think you
got to look that it was
a totally different era.
It sort of had followed not that
long after World War II, when
it still had the spirit
of whatever you got to do,
you got to do it quick
and done, because there's
a [? per ?] pressure.
And the aerospace
industry, for instance,
started with nothing when the--
'41.
And by '45, they had built
300,000 airplanes and bombers
and transports.
So they had an industry
that really tooled
up and moved fast.
And after Sputnik, we
were in another mode
of moving that way.
Some of us had worked
with [? Davy ?] [? Hoag ?]
on the Polaris, and we worked
on the guidance and so forth.
But those guys--
Admiral Rayburn and
the special projects--
they started, said go.
In 18 months, they had a
submarine built and ready
to take a missile by short--
I mean, imagine sitting down
now and telling somebody, go,
and building a
submarine and having it
out there in 18 months.
You couldn't do the
paperwork in 18 months.
But those guys really moved.
I never quite understood--
well, they took a submarine that
existed, and split it
in two, and redid--
it took all sorts
of tricks to do it.
But those of us
who worked on that
also saw that,
whatever you did, it
was going to move
very, very rapidly.
And we had [? Davy ?] [? Hoag ?]
to partition-- to lead us,
who was really a genius,
as far as I'm concerned.
A lot of us think he's the
mentor for engineering,
showed us what
engineering really was.
Then, when we moved to Apollo,
which [? Davy ?] said--
last time was August 8, 1961.
It was in Washington when they
awarded it, and some of us
were there then, so we were
there from even the start.
But it started, as Jim said.
Then they started to
put together teams.
There was a little
before, but not much.
And built it in late '61.
But you got to have two--
there's really two
distinct phases
with different objectives
and organization.
First is the
engineering phase that
lasted, well, two to
four or five years,
depending on what part.
And that's when you had
powered flight, rendezvous.
I was in the reentry.
Something else.
LEM later, but I don't know
that it started that way.
And you guys were
doing the simulator.
Who else?
There was about
five or six groups.
But it was definitely--
engineering organized
different parts of it.
And Dick [? Batten ?] was
the guy that ran all of it.
But we were all involved--
PRESENTER 5: Well, he
didn't really run it.
PRESENTER 4: He
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PRESENTER 4: He presided.
PRESENTER 5: And he
was real hands-off.
PRESENTER 4: Real hands-off.
PRESENTER 5: Just a guru--
PRESENTER 4: Right.
PRESENTER 5: --in
his corner office.
PRESENTER 4: Very
smart in his corner,
and smoked his pipe and nodded.
PRESENTER 5: Everybody thought
he was just writing a book,
but by golly, he knew
exactly what was going on.
And he didn't interfere.
And to me, that is one of
the secrets of success.
Again, as I said before, it
was the fewness of the people--
PRESENTER 4: Right.
PRESENTER 5: --that allowed
this massive project
to be shoehorned into
this teeny box, and work.
PRESENTER 4: Each of
those engineering groups
was quite small, as
[INAUDIBLE] said.
We had three or four in our
entry, and each of these others
didn't have a lot.
And you had a free hand.
NASA was very busy
with a lot of other--
they had a lot of
other things cooking.
So we had a lot of ability.
We went to these panel
meetings every month or two.
In my case, it was
Aaron [? Cohen. ?]
And a lot of other
NASA that you-- you
informed them what
you were doing,
and waited for
critical comments.
But you weren't ridden.
PRESENTER 5: Yeah.
I had a single point
of contact with NASA.
Tom Gibson, remember him?
PRESENTER 4: Right.
PRESENTER 5: The
cigar-chomping guy?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PRESENTER 5: He
oversaw our work.
But he didn't interfere.
PRESENTER 4: Right.
PRESENTER 5: We told him.
There were not
hordes of bureaucrats
who caused you to
fill in forms and make
present [INAUDIBLE] briefings
and that kind of crap.
We didn't have that at all.
You kept Tom happy, he
kept them off your back.
And you went on with
the engineering.
PRESENTER 4: But then we
awoke, several years later,
realizing we had a big
programming problem.
So we switched from
the engineering--
develop equations, make
simulations, study,
develop guidance equations.
We shifted to a different mode.
We had a program,
[? this ?] AGC.
And now, we needed
a new organization,
different people leading it.
The organization
changed entirely.
And now, it was more
mission-oriented,
where you integrated
all the needs into--
like, he started the 202
one, and different people
took over other ones, and
integrated the efforts
of these different groups,
and really had to program it.
Because in most
cases, the engineers
did a so-so
programming job, and it
had to be redone and put into
a form that would [INAUDIBLE]
consistent for a
particular flight.
And you found stupid errors
from engineers here and there,
like somebody, for
pi, using 22 over 7.
[LAUGHTER]
We kept getting errors,
and couldn't figure out.
And then this guy--
I mean, he was from
the old school.
[LAUGHTER]
[? Good ?] enough for--
PRESENTER 5: Good enough
for a [INAUDIBLE]..
Exactly.
PRESENTER 4: And there
were subtle errors
that even got to the flight.
You think Earth rate is
a well-known constant,
hasn't changed very much.
Earth rate is Earth rate.
But for us novices, although
we knew more at the time,
the earth rotates
once in 24 hours.
And that's what the guy
used on his calculation.
But that isn't right.
The Earth does not
rotate once in 24 hours.
24 hours is when it gets
back to the sun again.
But if you're doing the
Earth's rotation rate,
it actually rotates in about
23 hours and 56 minutes,
as I recall.
And if you use the
difference, your longitude
is going to be way
off, which it was.
And I can't remember what
early flight there was.
So things did get through.
But the programming effort
was directed differently
and organized differently.
And these guys really--
Margaret, Alex, Fred all really
took over and, in a very good,
delete all of those.
Then we had a break into
LEM versus command module.
LEM engineering took a lot
longer, because [? Grumman ?]
was longer, they didn't know--
some of us thought we were
done, and they were just almost
getting started,
Allen [? Klumpf. ?]
And then the auto
pilots came along, which
required some more engineering.
Anyway, I've--
PRESENTER 1: For
a long time, there
was a myth that was absolutely
nothing more than a myth,
that each mission program
was a slight enhancement
of the one that went before.
So that all you had to
do for the next one was
the enhancement.
The myth part was
that you had to start
all over again because
everything was different.
Somehow the hardware
was different
or the mission was different.
There were very
few things that--
PRESENTER 4: I think I'm
the only one that we flew
exactly the same thing twice.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't think there's any other.
Maybe [INAUDIBLE].
501 and 502 were identical
because they were unmanned.
There was nothing.
And I think it was
absolutely the same thing.
But I don't think we
did any others that way.
PRESENTER 1: But the
trouble is a lot of us
were fooled into believing
the myth somehow,
even after we knew it really
wasn't working that way.
And thought, with these
small groups of people,
we could handle it.
I remember these talks
in which we said,
we got to do this with either
about five people or maybe six.
Or we got to do it with 150.
The number we've got,
which is about 30 or 40,
is absolutely going to
kill us if we keep on.
We have to do either
one way or the other.
I think, happily,
we went to the 150,
although it wasn't
fun at the time.
PRESENTER 4: No, it
was very difficult.
PRESENTER 1: A
whole new culture.
PRESENTER 4: Especially when
you had what's-his-name from
IBM's--
Brooks [? Law, ?] that
adding more people
to a job that's in trouble makes
it later and things like that.
PRESENTER 1: We
couldn't figure out
why anybody else needed to
know what was in the guidance
computer besides us.
What does NASA need to know for?
Why do we have to publish
all these documents?
But we, of course, did have
to publish all that stuff.
Speaking of the point
that Fred apparently
raised in the prior meeting,
and that Dan touched on,
I remember--
I mentioned Hal
Laning, who had written
the executive for
the Mars computer,
and who stayed
involved for a while,
but decided he didn't like the
big money and the big pressure.
Got off.
But one day, there
was a meeting sort
of late in the Apollo
project, in which--
it was a two-day meeting at the
laboratory of about 30 people
to decide whether the executive
program for the shuttle
computer should be
[? interrupt-driven ?]
or schedule-driven.
And I'm not sure it
came to a conclusion
after 60 person days.
But Hal said to me,
these people have just
spent more time-- more
man days-- in that meeting
than it took me to conceive
of and write and debug
the executive for
the Apollo computer.
I mean, things just had
changed by orders of magnitude,
and it was clear to me it wasn't
going to be fun anymore to work
on that sort of
stuff, so I didn't.
PRESENTER 6: I'm very familiar
with this particular issue.
And I'll get into it
a little bit later.
It is the tail,
almost, of a long story
that I would categorize
as almost a religious war
between the synchronous
executive folks
and the [? interim ?]
priority-driven folks.
And it mushroomed in
the shuttle program,
and it had its roots in Apollo.
And perhaps, I'll get into
that a little bit later.
PRESENTER 1: You asked about
trust in automatic systems.
I remember-- just
a short anecdote.
We were visited at the
laboratory one day--
and I don't remember when,
but fairly early on--
by John Glenn and
[? Alan ?] Shepard,
and I think there was
a third astronaut.
I don't remember who.
And it was at the time
when reporters were still
chasing around after
the seven astronauts,
and it was a big thing when
the astronauts were coming.
And the laboratory was showing
those folks what we were doing.
And one of the things
that, at the time,
we kind of had the arrogance
to believe we should do
was to make sure
that nothing could
be done by mistake by the
crew that would endanger them.
So there were a
lot of tests that
said if the delta v is
in the wrong direction,
or this or that--
I can't remember what
all the conditions were.
There were lots of conditions.
Then they couldn't
execute the proceed order
to go ahead because
something was-- you know,
the software thought
something was wrong.
And [? Shepard, ?] with his
marvelous way about words,
I remember two
things he said there.
But this one, he
said, you guys think
you know more
about what is going
to face us during flight than
we will know during the flight.
He says, you're wrong.
He said, take all of
those inhibitions out.
He said, if we want to
kill ourselves, let us.
It may involve saving ourselves.
Anyway, of course he was right,
and I think everybody sort
of woke up to that.
It made the software
a lot easier, too,
[? because we didn't ?] have
to worry about all those
[? checks. ?]
[LAUGHTER]
But he was adamant about that.
PRESENTER 4: They did let him
start the pre-launch program
on the way--
PRESENTER 1: That's right.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, they weren't
capable of perfection.
They were pretty well-trained,
and they certainly
were motivated.
PRESENTER 4: They were very
well-trained, I will say that.
But they also got very tired.
PRESENTER 1: Yeah.
PRESENTER 4: I had
the reentry, which
is at the end of
five days out there.
And they swore, through
all the early years,
that they were going
to fly it manually.
And as far as I
know, none of them
ever touched the manual stick.
I mean, they were so beat.
And then, all of a
sudden, you hit seven G's.
I'm not sure they could even
see what was going on by then.
Because I mean, they
didn't get any sleep out
there for all that
time, really, did they?
I'm surprised they were as--
doing as well as they
did after all that time.
PRESENTER 7: Yeah.
I think [? our ?] we
had a different opinion
of this subject matter than
the astronauts did, or at least
the software group did,
at the time that this took
place, the pre-launch.
And we talked about
that the last time,
when he selected
pre-launch during flight.
So I think there's
sort of a in-between.
You don't want to
overdo it, but you also
want to make the
crucial areas, where
you can't have a catastrophe.
PRESENTER 1: Shepherd,
in that meeting,
was responsible, I think, for
the demise of another thought
that we had had, which
was that the computer, not
being perfectly
reliable, it was going
to be possible to do
in-flight repairs.
And so there were
a lot of thoughts
about diagnosing
what had gone wrong
and changing modules
and so forth.
I don't know how far along
that got, but [? Shepherd's ?]
comment to that was,
yeah, and we should all
train to be brain surgeons so
we can operate on each other.
And I think that was about the
end of the in-flight repair.
PRESENTER 6: I think
there were two areas here
that people are talking about
that somewhat different.
There was the small group,
seat-of-the-pants effort that
was unfettered and unhindered,
for the most part, by NASA,
and devoid, pretty much,
of real bureaucracy.
And I think that, as Dan
pointed out, you had--
a lot of the fundamental
engineering work
was done during that period.
And it was very
fortunate that we
were able to do it unfettered.
Because I think that a lot of
the fundamental issues on how
to get to the moon,
let's say, were solved
in this period of isolation--
almost isolation
[? and ?] small groups.
And these various
flights that have
been talked about, I think the
term-- when Alex was talking,
the term system mother
came into my head.
PRESENTER 1: [? Rope ?] mother.
PRESENTER 7: [? Rope ?] mother.
PRESENTER 6: Rope mother.
PRESENTER 1: Yes.
[INAUDIBLE]
PRESENTER 6: And this
was a person who was--
the responsibility was
focused upon this person
for a particular
flight, even though it
was a relatively small group.
But I think this era was--
I would say this is the
pre-built [INAUDIBLE] era.
And I think that,
somewhere along the line,
someone did some, let's
say, back-of-the-envelope
calculations about how many
lines of code we have to do,
how many person months--
how many lines of code per
person month and things
like that.
And came up with
a number of people
that were just completely
different than what the lab had
in doing this work.
So instead of
having 30 people, we
needed 200 people or
something like that.
And not only that, but we
needed all this documentation,
and we needed all
these review meetings,
NASA supervision,
and we needed a lot of stuff.
And at that point, there was a
LEM that was being split off,
and we sort of became quote,
unquote "professionalized,"
in the sense that I
remember one day--
and I can remember
the day very clearly.
There was an evening meeting
about 7:30 in the evening,
with Ralph Reagan
running the meeting.
And the lab has been under a lot
of pressure in previous weeks
with respect to NASA
coming down and questioning
their organization,
and questioning
their documentation, and
questioning their testing
and questioning everything.
And I was told, that
evening, that we're
going to have a
different organization
and we're going
to have something
called Project Managers.
And we didn't have
any project managers.
We didn't have
that title, anyway,
even though you might
think of a [? rope ?]
mother being a project manager.
And that's when I was
appointed the project
manager of CSM software.
And another individual,
George Cherry,
was appointed the project
manager of LEM software.
And these groups now
were fairly large,
and NASA wanted to
see formal schedules,
and time to complete
this module,
that module,
and reporting on a monthly--
I can't even remember the
schedule, what it was.
But things started to build up
in reviews and in paperwork,
and in monitoring and so on.
And I would say that that
became a different era
of doing work at
the lab, and much
less fun for a lot of people.
GEROVITCH: Excuse me.
Can you put a date
on that switch?
PRESENTER 4: It was after Gemini
that NASA descended on us,
but I don't know quite
when the date was.
PRESENTER 6: Yeah.
I would say--
I'm guessing, and I'm doing
it on my own time schedule.
I would say it's either--
it's either in the
fall of [? 1960-- ?] I
think it's the fall of 1966.
I don't think it's
into '67, But I--
PRESENTER 4: By '67, you
were [? in plates. ?]
PRESENTER 6: I think it
was the fall of 1966.
GEROVITCH: And what do you
think actually prompted
the change in NASA's attitude?
Was it the concern of one
particular [? faser? ?]
PRESENTER 6: Well, I think
that's a very good question,
and I have an
opinion, but it's just
a completely personal view.
The people at MIT were
very smart, very talented.
We certainly produced a lot.
But we were also, I think, sort
of arrogant from the outside.
And I think that that
arrogance started
to irritate people who were
tired of hearing that MIT
knew best, and knew better.
And you don't even
know what you want.
We know what you
want, and so on.
And I think that that was part
of why there was an effort
to almost sort of rein
in MIT, or to get them
on this program, not
their own program.
And then that NASA
is the boss, not MIT.
And I think there was
a little bit of that.
Plus, there may have been some
perfectly honest professionals
at NASA who had had experience
with large programs,
and just felt that
this was not going
to get there in the manner in
which it had been going so far.
GEROVITCH: So you don't
recall any particular conflict
that may have prompted NASA--
PRESENTER 4: Well,
those operations guys
that you see down in all those
rooms in Houston were doing
first Mercury and Gemini,
and zillions of [? them-- ?]
flight controllers.
And all of a sudden,
they said, now
what are we going
to do for Apollo?
And they had nothing in the
way of documents, procedures.
All of it was really scanty.
PRESENTER 6: [INAUDIBLE]
what they created, though,
[INAUDIBLE] as well.
I can remember this.
They had a--
NASA, at Houston, on this
seventh floor in Building 1,
I think.
They had this beautiful
conference room,
really beautiful
conference room.
And that's where they held a
lot of their big conferences.
And they built a wall
on this conference
room of sliding
translucent boards that
were like this blackboard--
whiteboard.
And they were white,
and they were--
they went deep, like six deep,
so that you could push one
and there was one behind
it, and push another one.
And you had a big, long-- it
was about the size of this wall,
and you could move things
from one side to the other
and so on.
And on this wall, they
created a schedule.
Today, we call it a Gantt chart.
And they had somebody who
was taking care of this.
Some contractor who would come
up every day with his blue tape
or red tape or
yellow tape, and mark
where the schedules were,
and all these things,
and what was going on.
And they could roll this board
back from that board and so on.
And this was being
kept, eventually,
daily by this contractor.
And it was
magnificent to see it.
That's how much they
got into the schedules
and sort of the project
management of the program.
PRESENTER 4: Yeah,
and MIT was woefully
unprepared for all the tons of
stuff and support and so forth.
So they had to
reorganize all together.
And it would have been--
I don't know how it
would have worked.
There were a few
people, like Fred,
who really did a great
job of dealing with them,
and trying to shape
the rest of us up,
put on some reasonable
form for it.
Plus, there was Bill Tindall,
that you have Tindall grams
that we dealt with,
who was up here a lot
trying to work the
problem, as they
would have said in those days.
And say what you may,
he did a great job
in trying to match the--
GEROVITCH: So were you seriously
adopting these techniques
in your own group,
or were you just
kind of shielding
that group from NASA,
allowing old practices
in the groups to go on?
PRESENTER 6: There was a
certain amount of shielding,
but I would have
to say, personally,
I was trying, as
a project manager,
to adopt project
management methods.
And I was trying to
keep track of schedules.
And I was trying to encourage
people to document things,
and put documentation in
listings and so on and so on.
So in that sense, I was
almost one of the enemy,
if you want to put it that way.
Because there are-- there were
a lot of people, and I'm sure,
looking back at it, people
would still have those feelings,
that this was just--
all this nonsense was
just getting in the way
of getting this job done.
Well, NASA just didn't
view it that way.
That was part of the job.
You had to work to schedules,
you had to work to--
you had to have reasons why
you couldn't meet a schedule.
You couldn't just say, well,
I promised this in two weeks
and I couldn't get it, you know?
PRESENTER 7: But I think
one thing that helped,
it was a matrix
management setup.
PRESENTER 6: It definitely was.
PRESENTER 7: And so Fred
and George, at that time,
were project managers,
but then there
were the functional managers.
So while they were worried about
the schedules of each mission,
from the functional
people worried about, hey,
is this stuff working--
the stuff we're supposed
to be delivering?
The actual-- maybe the
man-machine interface part.
This was a whole
separate division.
So the functional people and
the project managers would--
I thought they worked
together very well.
PRESENTER 6: Well, there
was a certain tension.
PRESENTER 7:
[? Didn't ?] [? we? ?]
PRESENTER 6: There's
always tension
in a matrix organization.
PRESENTER 7: Right?
PRESENTER 4: But
Fred did a great job.
PRESENTER 7: Yeah.
PRESENTER 4: Because
he came to us
and wasn't as high-handed
as some people at NASA,
and pounding on the table--
give me this or else.
PRESENTER 7: No, Fred was
like a psychiatrist project.
PRESENTER 6: Right.
You had to be a psychiatrist--
PRESENTER 4: He was--
PRESENTER 7: He made
everybody work together.
PRESENTER 5: Fred
was a psychiatrist
drawn from our ranks,
so he understood.
I always thought of you,
Fred, as Mr. Powered Flight.
That probably was a fairly
short period when you--
PRESENTER 1: It
was a short period.
PRESENTER 7: Yeah.
PRESENTER 5: But
that's what you were.
And you were one of
the guys that I needed.
PRESENTER 1: Was [? Ed ?] in
powered [? flight? ?] Who else
was in [? NASA? ?]
PRESENTER 4: I just
remembered Fred.
PRESENTER 5: Actually--
PRESENTER 6: You might say that,
from the background [? the ?]
people, it's interesting.
In those days,
we, of course, had
physicists on the job, and
mathematicians, and engineering
graduates and students.
We probably had a literature
major here and there, too,
who jumped in there.
But there was no computer
science discipline, as such.
There was nobody there who was
a computer scientist, per se.
PRESENTER 7: Did they even
teach computer science?
PRESENTER 6: And I don't
think that even taught it.
PRESENTER 7: It
was not a course.
PRESENTER 6: It
PRESENTER: Right, right.
PRESENTER 6: But I
often felt that part
of our success at that time
was due to the engineering
and physical science backgrounds
of a lot of those people.
Because maybe they weren't the
most elegant programmers, OK?
But they understood what a
specific impulse of an engine
was, or what the physics of
what you were trying to do.
And you weren't taking
somebody who was a--
sort of from the inside of a
computer, and then trying to--
who knew that, and
then trying to get
them to understand the problem
that you were trying to solve.
And I'm not saying
they couldn't do that,
but I'm just saying
that, at that time,
I thought that
one of the reasons
that we so rapidly
were able to do this--
I think there was a
great understanding
of what the problem
was, even if we
had to do some fast learning.
But people had the basic tools.
I think that was important.
PRESENTER 5: Yeah,
I remember-- [? I ?]
illustrated before, I remember
when you joined, Margaret.
And I didn't want to
tell this against you,
but one of the first things
I did in interfacing with you
was explain inertial
navigation system to you.
And you were a math major,
if I remember rightly.
And you hadn't worked--
you understood, but you hadn't
worked with coordinate systems,
and I spent a couple of
hours, a couple of days,
going through what the basis
of the guidance system was
and how it worked
and blah-blah-blah.
I never talked to her again
because you understood,
and you became an inertial--
at least somebody who knew
what inertial navigation
system-- how you describe
them and how you control them.
PRESENTER 6: I want to get
back something that Jim said,
and what he did in that group.
There was another fellow
who, perhaps, should be here,
as well, who also
contributed to that group,
[? that ?] is Bill
[? Wittennall. ?] We needed
those simulations so much
because it was the only thing
that grounded us to
what the truth was.
I mean, you could
never tell what
you were doing was going
to work until you banged it
against a simulator.
PRESENTER 7: Unless the
simulation was wrong.
PRESENTER 6: Unless the
simulation was wrong,
and I didn't--
I suppose that happened.
I don't remember too many--
PRESENTER 4: But that's
why it was so important.
PRESENTER 6: I don't
remember too many times,
and I was really
impressed when somebody
had five degrees of freedom
in the fuel [? slashing ?]
module of the vehicle.
And they had all the stars in
the right places, and all the--
everything else
that would happen.
And it was really--
it became our truth.
And I was thinking
about this last night
before I came here, also.
This was, basically,
a fun project,
although there were
plenty of difficult times
in the project when you're
in the middle of it.
But I was-- we did a lot
of testing in this project,
a lot of testing with
these simulators.
And I think that
if all we ever did
was fly the nominal
mission with nothing wrong,
it would've been pretty
boring after a while,
if you had this just
one set of parameters,
and you always fly this
one set of parameters.
And I think that part
of the fun that we
had was thinking up and creating
these crazy off-nominal cases
that probably could
never, never happen.
And then see-- and then bang
that against the software that
we designed, and design certain
margins into the software that
would make sure that if you--
which way, or what
way the [? gimbal ?]
would go that you'd be
able to get out of it.
And other things that made
such variety in the testing.
That for one nominal case,
we ran 100 off-nominal cases.
PRESENTER 7: Also, an advantage,
from a computer science
or software engineering
point of view,
of having different missions
is that we learned all
about the advantages of things
that people don't think too
much about today,
like reuse and how
that could cut down on testing.
We learned all the
things about what
it means to manage these
different missions, what's
reused between the LEM
and the command module,
between this mission and
the one that's going next.
How do you evolve?
How do you do it
in a reliable way?
In other words, it
was a great place
to learn about how to
do things the right way.
So that was--
PRESENTER 6: The whole thing
had to be structured, too.
I mean, all that
software had to be--
we structured it into
programs with numbers.
We'd call them things.
We had names for them.
The astronauts eventually picked
up some of those same names.
They would get into P40.
I mean, they didn't
know what P40 was.
These things were-- not that
those names were so great,
but the fact of the matter
is that that software all had
to be structured and organized.
And there had to be
a nomenclature on it,
and there had to be
interfaces built.
PRESENTER 7: It took
on a life of their own.
PRESENTER 6: It took
on a life of its own.
PRESENTER 4: --banks
manually here, there.
PRESENTER 6: Right.
PRESENTER 3: And it had to
be ready about-- what was it?
8, 10 weeks before flight time.
You couldn't change
it after that.
PRESENTER: At least.
PRESENTER 7: And
also, we learned
about how important
it was to prioritize
as to what was most important.
Because there was so little room
to put the programs into that
you would learn to delete
what was less important.
But prioritizing
became something,
and backup systems
also became something
that you lived your life
later by doing things
like prioritizing,
and doing things
like having backup systems.
[? And ?] in your daily life--
and even going to the
grocery store later on,
it was such an influence.
But we had a Black Friday--
I can't remember what
Black Friday was.
I just remember we were
deleting all kinds of things
because something more
important was coming in.
What was it?
PRESENTER 4: [INAUDIBLE]
sessions where they cut--
PRESENTER 7: Yeah.
PRESENTER 6: [INAUDIBLE] I think
they called it Black Friday.
PRESENTER 7: Yeah.
But we deleted an awful lot
because something really
important had to be done.
Maybe it was backups or--
I don't remember now.
I wrote about it, but I
can't remember what it--
I'll have to go back
and find that out.
PRESENTER 3: I'm sorry
to have to leave,
but thank you very much.
PRESENTER 4: Ray,
nice to see you again.
PRESENTER: Good to see you, Ray.
PRESENTER 6: Ray,
were you the guy who--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PRESENTER 6: Ray,
were you the person
who inflicted banks on us
so we had to worry about--
PRESENTER 3: That was a
solution to a very bad problem.
PRESENTER 6: It was a very bad
[LAUGHTER]
PRESENTER 3: Well, that solution
exists today in Windows, right?
Or in the 8086 architecture.
Because you still
have to do banking
in order to get the
extended address
fields and things like that.
PRESENTER: Right.
PRESENTER 2: It's
just invisible.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PRESENTER 6: It drove us
bananas, I'll tell you that.
It was almost like
area codes, I would
say, in the telephone system.
I mean, you had to--
PRESENTER 7: Oh, yeah.
PRESENTER 6: --you had to be
able to address [? this-- ?]
with the [? addressing-- ?]
how many bits you had
for addressing.
And in order to get
unique addressing,
you had to mark it with
another set of field--
another field that would
let you address uniquely.
And so you had to
manage that other field,
and that got very
confusing in the software.
That was a difficult issue.
PRESENTER 4: And the
erasable memory was so small.
What was it?
2K?
PRESENTER: It was about 2K.
PRESENTER 4: That certain
of that was permanent,
but a lot of it
used during burn.
And when you were done
burns, that same area
was used for something
in a later phase.
And so these phases
were sequential.
And all the previous information
was gone, and not used anymore.
So you didn't have unique--
PRESENTER 7: You
could see there were
a lot of things to do with
interfacing correctly.
And therefore, we
had the opportunity
to make a lot of
interface errors
because we had to
squeeze everything
into such a small space.
But also, it's amazing what one
could do in so little space.
And how little one can do
with so much space today.
[LAUGHTER]
PRESENTER 5: One of the
things that I have remarked on
to myself, over 30 years
since then, is at the time,
we brought software
into a machine
that, by today's
standards, would be
a very advanced architecture.
I mean, we had-- you
heard it all the time--
preemptive,
event-driven executives.
I mean, I've worked with
people who say, what?
You programmed
into one of those?
A real-time control computer
with event-driven asynchronous?
We don't have that today.
PRESENTER 4: Yeah, with
auto pilots and [? jets ?]
sending signals.
PRESENTER 5: Multiple levels
of interrupts and control.
PRESENTER 7: Man-machine
interface, all of it.
PRESENTER 5: We invented
it for this job,
and it hasn't reemerged as a
standard of computer design
today.
Surely, there are
interrupts and stuff
like-- but they were not used
in this coordinated fashion
that we had then.
Something else
that we invented--
and it's saved those guys
[INAUDIBLE] on the moon--
was the software restart, which
allowed reaction to any kind
of failure for the computer to
retrack back to its last known,
properly coordinated state,
and to [? re-move ?] forward.
PRESENTER 4: You don't have
to do Control-Alt-Delete.
PRESENTER 5: No.
This thing sets-- what
do we call those things?
PRESENTER 4: Restart points.
PRESENTER 5: Restart
points as it went along.
PRESENTER 7: And Dan
was the father of that.
PRESENTER 5: I was going
to say, this guy and Woody
[? Vandiver-- ?] I was--
Dan's the father.
Woody was the guy
that put together--
and I advised that
Woody should be.
[INAUDIBLE] But not only did
the software restart concept,
I think, rescue the
LEM from failure
just as the [INAUDIBLE]
[? touched ?] down,
they were also a terrific
help in debugging
this complex piece of software.
We used them.
Do you remember that?
PRESENTER 7: Yeah.
PRESENTER 5: We
triggered restarts,
because if this thing was able
to go over the same piece,
we could change things
and rerun chunks
using the characteristics
of the software itself.
But I think Margaret probably
remembers more of that
than I do.
But I remember, if
we did not have that,
testing of this real-time stuff
would have been a hell of a lot
more difficult.
PRESENTER 7: Well, you
brought up something
that was really interesting.
Because people today,
when they use computers,
they try something, it doesn't
work, they try something again,
it doesn't work,
and they just have
the computer at their disposal.
We could only put
in runs overnight.
So you'd have to
think very carefully.
Because if it didn't
work, then you'd
have to wait till the next day.
PRESENTER 5: You wasted a day.
PRESENTER 7: A whole day.
So then what we
learned to do was
to find a way to run 100 runs
at once, thinking about it
before the fact, and the
restarts remind me of that.
So you'd try all these
different things all at once.
And in a way, you got
more done because you had
to think it out so carefully.
You got done maybe more
in that 24-hour period
than if you were
sitting here, ad
[? hocly, ?] just
trying something.
And so you're basically doing
things more in parallel,
I think, in your
thinking process
and your design of the test.
So that was a
totally different--
PRESENTER 5: Yeah.
I don't know what lessons
can be learned from that,
but we did this
with cards offline.
PRESENTER 7: Yeah, cards.
PRESENTER: Punch cards.
PRESENTER 5: There
were no such things
as terminals or interaction.
As Margaret said, you got
your stack of 2,000 cards.
You gave it to the guys in the
computer room, who by then, had
cordoned themselves off.
You couldn't-- we used to
go in there and run the runs
ourselves, but that--
at some stage, when Jim's
double Honeywell came in,
that was the end of that.
PRESENTER 7: And the thing
is, if you dropped the cards,
you had a real problem.
[LAUGHTER]
But it made you realize--
I mean, that was
part of the reason
we worked on doing
something where,
if you drop the
instruction sets,
it wouldn't matter because
it was smart enough
to get it back together again.
That was later.
But we used to take
pieces like cards
and say, here, put
this in your deck,
and that would be the reusable.
You remember that?
PRESENTER 5: Yeah.
PRESENTER 4: We had
to learn to use 519's.
PRESENTER 5: These are like
horror stories, or war stories.
There's probably something to
be learned from this experience
that the few, under
arduous circumstances,
were able to turn out
something as complex
as this piece of software was,
and have it work-- and prove
that it worked.
That seems to be missing today.
I don't know how to
put that together,
but the fewer people, and the
more crude the development
environment was,
the better seemed
to have been the progress
and the end product.
There's a conundrum there.
I'm not sure what it is.
PRESENTER 6: We did something
that I know Margaret
was intimately involved with.
And that is that--
and I think it's
written up in Microsoft's method
of doing their software today.
But we had a nightly
configuration control
group that looked
at all changes that
were created by
anybody during the day,
and had to pass this little
group of people, which
might have been four people.
And we had the--
PRESENTER 7: The
[? rope ?] mothers.
PRESENTER 6: We had
this, quote, "advantage"
of doing an assembly
every night so
that these changes were
brought in to one listing,
you might say.
And then, by the next day, you'd
have an update of that program.
And so you had a very--
an extremely tight
configuration control system.
Today, if everybody is
programming on monitors,
and they're all
distributed and so on.
This is a much more
difficult environment
than we were in
this one building,
everybody producing
changes and cards,
and write-ups of what
their changes were, all
being funneled to one
small configuration control
group, who would then
pass on everything
that went into that system.
And that was done continuously.
I don't know if it
started right at day one,
but it was done on the
flights that I remember.
And it was a very effective
way of keeping errors out
of the program.
PRESENTER 7: But
there was more to add
to that, in that every single
day, the person who reviewed
the changes would put out a memo
that would go to everyone that
was involved in that
mission, so that they were
aware of what the changes were.
So then, if they
had problems, they'd
know that a change had
been made in that area.
So it was that communication--
just hard-copy
memos that went out
alongside each daily
revision that I think helped.
PRESENTER 1: It shouldn't
be forgotten that this was
an assembly language program.
PRESENTER 6: Yes.
PRESENTER 7: Yeah.
PRESENTER 1: And if
somebody had set up
a simulation with what we call
special requests, addressed
to certain locations,
and somebody changed
the underlying
stuff, the locations
could move in that
simulation run,
or just be incorrectly
formulated,
as it would turn out.
But that would take a day.
And so you had to be
careful not to kill somebody
by shooting down
something somebody else
was planning to do with
a fixed configuration.
PRESENTER 7: Exactly.
PRESENTER 1: Which was never
fixed because somebody had
to change something every day.
Towards the end
of the development
of a single mission program--
this is a fascinating thing.
It's been mentioned that NASA
let us do just about anything
we wanted to in the code.
But we did have some help from
a famous guy [? at ?] [? TRW. ?]
But basically, we were
completely given free reign
until we delivered the software
to Raytheon to build the core
[? rope. ?]
And then we would go
into a series of tests
with absolutely
fixed configuration,
the purpose being
to find any more
bugs that hadn't been found.
And sometimes, when you found--
sometimes you would
find bugs that just
you felt had to be fixed.
And usually, they could be.
But once the program
was delivered,
this group of people,
who were the only people
in the world who NASA thought
could write the software,
suddenly were so stupid
that no change they proposed
could be plausible at all.
And so anything you
suggested, the answer was no.
And you had to beg and so
forth, for the interest
of the project, to
be allowed to remove
this desperately bad thing.
And I remember one night,
in the LEM 1 software game,
when one of these showed up.
Probably the digital
autopilot, which was new.
And it was late at night.
It must have been 9:00
or 10:00 at night.
And I called the
guy, and I'm not
going to mention any names
for reasons that you'll see.
I called the guy who was
monitoring us at NASA at home
because I had to
get his permission
to put this change in, and to
let him know it was coming.
And his wife answered the
phone and said he was at work.
So I called him at his office.
Nobody there.
Well, I knew that this
guy wasn't always telling
his wife what he was up
to, to say the least.
And here I was
with this problem.
It was 10 o'clock at night.
We wanted to put this change in.
It was, in my mind--
whatever it was--
really important to
put this change in.
I knew the guy wasn't where
his wife thought he was,
and I didn't know what to do.
I couldn't leave
a message at work
because they didn't
have voicemail then.
And I didn't want to
call his wife back
and say he wasn't at work,
for fear of what would
happen to him when he got home.
And what do you do
in a case like that?
We were absolutely at the
mercy of getting approval
on those things.
I don't remember what happened.
PRESENTER 7: He was
in the bathroom.
PRESENTER 1: I doubt it.
But there were some funny
situations like that.
Many times, the
software was changed
after the rope had
actually been built,
and they would sometimes
have already potted it,
and they'd have to depot it, and
change the wires and so forth.
It was an incredibly small and
arduous process to go through.
One of the things that I think
deserves mention to illustrate
the frugality that went into
the design and the software was
that the guys that invented
these interpreters--
and we had a second generation
of them later than the one that
Hal Laning had developed--
realized that
single precision was
too small to do
Earth-to-moon navigation,
but double precision
was adequate.
And so the interpreter would do
everything in double precision,
or lots of things
in double precision.
It was a ones'
complement machine, which
is funny enough by itself.
So that there were 32,767
states, not 32,768 states.
And unfortunately, there
were some optical encoders
on rotating gadgets that needed
2 to the 15th exactly, and not
2 to the 15th minus 1.
And so it also was
capable of doing
[? two's ?]
[? complement ?] arithmetic,
which caused some
other problems.
But here we had a ones'
complement machine
with two forms of 0.
And double precision,
in which the interpreter
was perfectly happy to let the
two parts of the [? word ?]
have different signs.
So you could have a plus 1 over
here and a minus 1/2 over here,
and the result would
be whatever it is.
Plus 1/2.
And that was clever
because the software
to do sign correction
all the time
took time, took space,
and was eliminated.
Unfortunately,
however, there were
a lot of cases where
that just turned out
to be a real pain
in the backside.
And there were lots
and lots of little bugs
that showed up when there was
sign disagreement in there,
in a way that somehow got
through all the checks.
And so there were things that
we did to ourselves sometimes,
in the interest of frugality,
or [? needed ?] to.
It was a different day.
Dan, of course, solved the
assembly language problem.
He solved lots of problems.
Wrote an assembler.
We had an assembler on
the Honeywell machine,
which was a batch assembly.
You would take all of
the assembly programs
that you were going
to update, and you
would assemble this
huge deck of cards
that would affect all of them.
And one of the characteristics
of this assembler
was it was designed
for the tape machine,
so it had tapes up and
down, and so forth.
If your cards were
in the wrong place,
or had the wrong
number on them, they
wouldn't go where
you put them in,
and they wouldn't necessarily
even go into the program
that you had them aimed at.
And so you had to meticulously
check your assembly listing
in the morning when you got up
to see if all your changes went
in there.
And if they weren't
where you expected them,
you had to go try to figure
out, where did they go?
And it was an arduous
process, and a careless person
could wreak havoc on the
world in those assemblies.
And they would run
for a long time.
The saving grace of the Apollo
computer was that it was slow.
And why I say that was that
the simulations that we
did, and the assemblies we
had to do, were very long.
And if the machine had
been 10 times as fast,
it would have taken 10 times
longer on the best hardware
that we could buy to
simulate this stuff.
And we would never have been
able to run these simulations.
They would have
just taken more time
than we could've possibly had.
So sometimes, the
limited resources
are a blessing in disguise.
PRESENTER 4: That's
why those emulators
people have on today's
computers have so much trouble.
They're trying to emulate
something that's so fast.
PRESENTER 1: Exactly.
We had things in the simulation
called clock advance, which
you'd tell a simulator you
were willing-- when nothing was
happening-- to just jump
the clock up to the point
where something happened.
And the simulator would
figure out when that was,
and just take that
leap up there.
PRESENTER 7: That's great.
I really liked that.
PRESENTER 1: And
it really advanced
the speed of the
simulation to the point
where it was nearly real
time in a lot of cases,
dependent on how busy
the computer was.
But there were lots of periods
where it was just idling,
and maybe a few instructions,
or maybe a few seconds.
But it would just leap
the clock forward.
And that, as far as I know,
never caused any difficulties.
Because we didn't
pass anything where,
if an interrupt happened,
that's where we'd go
or something else.
There [? were ?] a lot
of tricky stuff in there.
PRESENTER 7: I
keep telling people
what that simulator used to
do, and they can't believe it.
[? It's ?] many things
it did that people
don't do today that
they should do.
PRESENTER 1: One of the
fascinating problems
was the reuse of
erasable memory.
And like every memory
problem, a piece
of software that would
use somebody else's memory
would likely get away
with it because if it
started writing into that
area, and then completed what
it would do, it would go away.
And then the person who had left
something in there for its use
when it came back
would hit something
that somebody else
had written in there,
and do it completely wrong.
And then, by then, the
real violator was long gone
and you had to figure
out who did it.
PRESENTER 4: Who done it?
PRESENTER 1: And there
were also problems
of using erasable that
hadn't been initialized
the way you thought it had.
And we came up with a technique
to put a kind of random number
into all of erasable
when we started.
PRESENTER 7: In the background.
PRESENTER 1: And if that was
ever hit, you could see it,
and we had a way to put
that same random number back
in so you could do all kinds
of diagnosis to find it.
There were just things
that nobody does anymore.
PRESENTER 4: You know, they
still haven't solved that.
You don't know how many
students of mine now,
their programs only
work when they're
0 in the location
when they start.
That's the worst
thing, I've decided,
that you can put
in [? unused-- ?]
PRESENTER 1: Yeah, that's right.
PRESENTER 7: But why aren't
people doing these things?
There are so many
things that would really
help debug systems today that
never were brought forward.
Many things are, but that
was one that was, I think,
more advanced than most
debugging tools we have.
Why do you think that is?
GEROVITCH: Was there any
effort to disseminate,
in a systematic way, the kind
of knowledge and programming
that you gained
within that project
to flesh out the most
important principles that
were worked out in the work of
this project, and published?
PRESENTER 6: There have been a
few summaries of the program.
People have written volumes
I think that you probably
have gotten your hands on.
I know there was a
late volume written
by that woman,
[? Madeline ?] Sullivan?
And sometime, she wrote a
multi-volume history of Apollo.
I think it was one
of the lab documents.
But I don't know
that anybody has
tried to record the essence
of, let's say, programming
breakthroughs, or programming
inventions, or something
of that nature.
Or the salient discoveries,
if you will, in the Apollo.
I haven't seen
anything like that.
PRESENTER 4: No,
I don't think so.
Some parts of the
engineering have been
covered with some good papers--
well, [? Batten's ?] got a book,
but that's more theoretical.
But haven't there been some
papers on LEM's autopilot lunar
landing?
PRESENTER 6: Perhaps.
I haven't--
PRESENTER 1: Bill wrote--
Bill [? Wittennall ?]
wrote a book on autopilot.
PRESENTER 4: Right.
PRESENTER 1: I think it
was the CSM autopilot.
PRESENTER 4: Right.
PRESENTER 1: Published
by MIT Press.
PRESENTER 4: That's
vaguely coming back.
Maybe that's--
PRESENTER 1: But
not too many people
were thinking of publishing.
They were trying
to just get home.
I mean, I don't
know how many people
were working six or seven-day
weeks, 80-hour weeks,
and doing everything
they possibly could
in their power to get these
guys to the moon and back.
PRESENTER 5: A
number of marriages
sank during that
period, including mine.
PRESENTER 6: I think there was
an element in this program that
is missing in a lot
of current programs.
And the 60, 70-hour week
that we just spoke about,
I'm sure that people
do that today, too.
But there was an--
I don't know how to say this--
an immediacy, or a familiarity
with the astronauts.
I'm talking about people
at MIT, but it's probably
true in other parts
of the Apollo program.
That you felt a certain
personal responsibility to--
either you made promises,
or you had conversations
with these people,
or you were doing it
because you wanted to make sure
that there was absolutely zero
errors in this program.
Because you knew that
their lives were at stake.
There was some sort of
connection to the astronauts
that we at--
I felt, and I think other
people at MIT felt--
perhaps because they
came there for training.
Or I know there were occasions
we went to dinner with Doc
Draper at [? Lockovers ?]
with some of the astronauts
after a flight.
And I think that affected some--
or kept morale up, and kept
people's attention, and feeling
of dedication to the job because
of that sort of connection.
You weren't working for
some big-- necessarily some
big bureaucracy.
It was this-- in my case, it
was sort of a feeling that--
some sort of connection
with Chris [? Craft, ?]
that you were satisfying his
leadership, you might say.
Plus this feeling-- this sort
of feeling of the astronauts,
I would say, that certainly
affected me in the job.
PRESENTER 4: Absolutely.
They were here.
I mean, which Apollo flight had
Jim [? McDevit, ?] Dave Scott,
and Rusty [? Schweiker? ?]
That was Apollo 7, 8?
Whatever.
But they seemed to be around
frequently before that,
and you just seemed to
see them doing this stuff,
and get to know what they
were doing all the time.
It felt very close.
In fact, we used to
laugh at them picking
on Dave [? Scott. ?] He wasn't
quite as fast picking up
the stuff when you
showed them that.
But they were there frequently.
But even before that, I
remember the first time
we went to Houston and gave a
presentation to a lot of them,
that was earlier in the--
still in the engineering mode.
I mean, these guys
came out and--
[GASPS]
They didn't just sit
there and nod off.
They were excited, and asked--
I remember Neil
Armstrong overwhelmed me
with the questions he asked,
and how well-prepared,
and how thoughtful.
And I said, jeez, these guys,
there's no fooling them.
They know what
they're looking for,
and we better be really careful
of what's going on here,
and make sure we're prepared.
When they ask questions like
that, you can't wing it.
GEROVITCH: Were they
actually interested
in software, as such?
PRESENTER 6: Some
were, actually.
PRESENTER 5: Not per se.
PRESENTER 4: But they wanted
to know how this worked,
and what was going to happen,
and what it meant to them,
and how it--
PRESENTER 5: They worked
through the controls,
but a lot of the controls
were driven by the software.
So what they said or didn't say
had an immediate impact on us,
who were making those
things work in the front,
through the software itself.
I remember Steve
[INAUDIBLE] was the man--
I've forgotten what the
hell that thing was.
PRESENTER 4: Oh,
you should mention--
PRESENTER 5: The
astronaut document
that gave the whole sequences
of all of [INAUDIBLE]..
PRESENTER 4: Right.
The word for John [INAUDIBLE].
What's the name of it?
PRESENTER 7: The [? GSOP. ?]
PRESENTER 5: The guidance
systems operations plan.
PRESENTER 4: Steve and
Malcolm and Jack Schilling
all cranked out all that stuff
that went on and on and on.
PRESENTER 5: This
was the first time
I'd ever seen a
specification for anything.
And today, you design
the spec first,
and the software
falls out the bottom.
But those GSOPs, I
remember John [? Dolan ?]
was the guy-- remember him?
PRESENTER 4: Yeah, yeah.
PRESENTER 5: The man with the
eight kids, I think he had.
PRESENTER 4: That's right.
PRESENTER 5: Who lived
in the South Shore
somewhere, and came
into work every day.
PRESENTER 4: That
was a thankless task,
churning out all that stuff.
PRESENTER 5: Yep.
PRESENTER 4: And you
had to get it all--
PRESENTER 5: Because he was--
the astronaut--
PRESENTER 4: They had to run
down and catch us to get--
PRESENTER 5: Yeah.
PRESENTER 4: Every time
they had a question,
they'd start-- can I
talk to you a minute?
PRESENTER 5: Yeah.
PRESENTER 6: I still have
something like 280,000 Eastern
Airlines miles that are now
part of the Continental system
that never expire.
And--
PRESENTER 1: Look out.
PRESENTER 6: These were
on these multiple--
PRESENTER 1: Midway has
already thrown in the towel.
Who's next?
PRESENTER 6: Multiple
trips to Houston.
But one of them, I want to just
bring up in the conversation
here.
I don't know how many trips
we all made to Houston.
I can remember--
I can just see myself having
this heated discussion
for an hour and a half
between Boston and Atlanta
with Margaret on some
programming issue,
or something that we were doing.
But we attended innumerable
meetings down at NASA,
and we had a very
live wire at NASA who
we went to see all the time.
And that was this guy Jack
[? Garmin, ?] who really was--
he really-- if there was anybody
at NASA who sort of understood
what we were trying to
do, it was this guy,
Jack [? Garmin. ?] And--
PRESENTER 4: I think--
I always felt like
Dr. Frankenstein,
that I'd created a monster.
PRESENTER 6: Yeah.
PRESENTER 4: He
got assigned to me,
and for six months, an
hour a day, I'd keep--
PRESENTER 6: He was--
PRESENTER 4: --telling him the
stuff, and he was persistent.
Phone calls, phone
calls, phone--
PRESENTER 6: But I remember
this day, this particular day
that [? I had ?] finished
a meeting at NASA,
and I was coming home.
And we were standing--
I guess walking between the
parking lot and the terminal.
It was like a driveway
that headed up
toward the terminal in Houston.
I can't remember whether this
was Hobby or the International.
I can't really remember.
But anyway, everybody
said, well, wait a minute.
There's the President.
And so we watched, and this open
car came from the terminal--
passed us.
And there weren't very many
people standing around.
Maybe one deep
along the road that
might have been 1/2 a mile long.
And he rode by in an open
car with his wife at maybe--
I thought it was around
15 miles an hour,
but nothing faster than that.
Maybe 20.
And I remember standing there.
I don't know who was with me.
And I said something
like, you know,
if anybody wanted to kill this
guy, this would be pretty easy.
Because he's just rolling
by in an open car and so on.
Well that was November 21, 1963.
And I think it was a Thursday,
I think, and I was coming home.
And I was in my
office the next day.
And he was no longer in Houston.
He had gone that night, and then
he went to Dallas the next day.
PRESENTER 4: Yeah, I went
there that same Thursday.
I think it was a
different meeting.
And he went right down--
we were-- they hadn't
built that MSC yet.
We were in Houston.
It was an office park,
whatever it was called.
And he went right down
the main highway there,
although we didn't
go out and see him.
But I stayed over till
Friday, and then Friday, I
was heading to go home.
And then, at the airport,
we got all this news.
And--
PRESENTER 5: But do you
think it was a Friday?
PRESENTER 4: Yeah.
PRESENTER 5: Yeah.
That's my recollection.
PRESENTER 4: Yeah.
But Thursday, he was in
Houston, and went up and down
whatever the name of
that [? Gulf ?] freeway,
or whatever it is.
There was a parade or something.
And then Friday--
I stayed over Thursday
night, some more meetings
Friday morning.
Was heading home
Friday afternoon,
and then, in the Hobby Airport,
we heard the first news
that all of this had happened.
PRESENTER 6: I wanted to touch
upon this religious war I
mentioned before, and get
into it just for a moment.
The issue really came to a
head in the shuttle program,
where there were
forces that believed
in asynchronous,
priority-driven,
interrupt-driven executives.
And other forces that
believed in absolutely
synchronous executives,
where you planned out
all the software,
and you executed
the software by tables.
And you could tell what
part of the software
was operating at
every instant of time
because you had planned
it out so that it all
operated very rigidly.
And the people who really
used those kinds of executives
were mostly people in
the aircraft industry.
And they had come from
various airplanes, where
they had these
computers and they had
these synchronous executives.
And it was very
important for them
to know exactly
what was happening
at every instant of time,
either from a testing standpoint
or whatever.
That was their mindset.
And the people that had worked
on Apollo, for the most part,
believed in this
asynchronous executive, where
you have priorities
and you didn't
have everything
structured completely,
but you allowed
higher priority jobs
to interrupt lower
priority jobs, and so on.
And there were these
incredible discussions
in the early shuttle
time, in deciding
what kind of an executive
should be used in the--
operating system should
be used in the shuttle.
And the shuttle had its
own hardware issues,
with multi-reliability
strings and IO processor,
and other things that
had to be synced.
And so it had a lot of reasons
why this was a big issue.
But the roots of
the Apollo viewpoint
really stemmed back
to the alarms that
occurred on the lunar landing.
And as you recall, in that
flight when that LEM was coming
down, and all of a sudden,
he had these alarms,
and the astronaut kept
getting these alarms.
He said that he had
alarms and, finally,
there was a decision in
Houston to just push on,
and that he should land.
And whoever made that decision--
Steve [? Bailes ?]
or whoever it was--
either he understood
what the problem was,
or he felt that he--
PRESENTER 4: Well, Jack
[? Garmin ?] was screaming--
I heard it-- go, go, go, go.
And I don't think he
had any evidence other
than he thought we had
restarted it perfectly.
PRESENTER 6: Anyway,
he landed safely.
And following that
landing, there
was just a frantic
session at the MIT lab
to find out what in the world
was causing these alarms.
And it took us the better
part of 24 hours, I think,
as I recall.
And going back to the
simulators, we simulated this.
We tried everything
to make this happen,
and we could not
make this happen.
It was as if the AGC was
operating at about 25% slower
than it usually operates.
And so we tried lots of things,
and we couldn't make it happen.
Eventually, [? over ?] the
suggestion of somebody who
worked at the Cape a lot,
we tracked down the fact
that they had a switch
in the wrong position,
and it was stealing cycles.
And there was a radar
rendezvous switch,
and that made the
AGC run slower.
And because it was
running slower,
it was dropping
low-priority jobs,
and not getting to
these low-priority jobs.
And only doing the
highest-priority jobs.
And so the job queue
filled up, and when
the job queue filled
up, it caused this alarm
to go off and so on.
At any rate, MIT got
a lot of criticism
for software era
causing this to happen.
And so now you had
sort of a dichotomy,
where people believed
that what had happened
was actually an error, and
other people believed, no,
the software actually
saved the program.
Because in the face of
this mistake in the switch,
the software, which was written
as a priority executive,
was able to go on with the
highest-priority jobs, and not
tank the mission
because it didn't
have to do this
boxcar-structured, synchronous
system, where it would
give time to everything,
whether it was important or not.
PRESENTER 7: Well,
you know, it was
even more complicated than
that because the error was
in the actual documentation.
PRESENTER 6: Yes, I was going
to mention that in a moment.
So this feeling went forward,
including the NASA folks--
people like Jack
Garmin, who absolutely
felt that it was important to
have such a system in shuttle--
versus the airplane folks,
who felt that they could never
be able to test the
software afterward
if they couldn't have an exact
match, and know exactly what
happened at any time.
And the asynchronous
executive was almost not
repeatable, you might say.
So that caused a great
deal of difficulty.
What Margaret is pointing
out is that, when we finally
got, and found--
I remember the incident
that we ran upstairs--
PRESENTER 4: [? Ross ?] Larson.
PRESENTER 6: --to
look at the telemetry
to see where the bits were set.
And sure enough, the
[? radars ?] bit-- the switch--
the bit, which was picked up
by telemetry and downloaded,
that was in, let's say, 15-bit
[? or ?] how many [? bits-- ?]
[? words ?] there
were in the telemetry,
and bit [? 9, ?]
or whatever it was,
showed that the switch was on.
PRESENTER 4: Rendezvous radar.
PRESENTER 6: Right.
Which meant that
that's what it was.
And eventually, they told--
the ground told
the astronaut, when
he was about to take
off from the moon,
to put the switch in
the right position,
he said, in a very
low-key fashion.
But when that was
run down to the end,
it was found in
the crew procedures
to put the switch
in this position.
So the next question
was, well, how
come, if you put the
switch in this position,
wasn't this picked
up in the simulators
at Grumman, which these
guys had been training on
for, I don't know,
a couple of years.
And in that crew
simulator, they had always
done exactly what was
in the document, put
the switch in that position.
However, that switch wasn't
connected to anything.
In other words,
that switch was not
connected, in the simulator, to
the AGC, which would slow them
down in that simulator.
PRESENTER 4: You
mean at Grumman?
PRESENTER 6: At Grumman.
So they did-- they
trained exactly
to what those crew
procedures said each time,
and they did it on
the landing, too.
PRESENTER 7: Well,
it kind of gives you
an understanding more of
how important everything is
with respect to the
entire system of software,
[? peopleware, ?]
you know, that--
PRESENTER 4: And I
put it the other way.
Why didn't our simulations
follow the crew procedures?
PRESENTER 6: I don't
know that the crew did
that in our simulations.
I don't know.
It probably didn't--
I don't think it was in
our digital simulator.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PRESENTER 4: --if I turned
on the rendezvous radar?
PRESENTER 6: I don't know.
PRESENTER 7: But
when you're testing--
back to the system thing--
what would make the software
do something like that?
In other words,
you begin to think
in terms of modeling
and designing a problem.
And where do you stop?
Where's the outside
of the outside?
But it's modeling all
these things as one system
of which part is
realized as software,
part as [? peopleware, ?]
part as hardware.
But then, you begin to model
it as an entire enterprise,
and then simulate
it as an enterprise.
But it makes you realize that
when people blame something
as being a software error
or a hardware error,
you're not necessarily
sure what is it,
and what does it mean to be a
software error or a hardware
error?
And this brings up
all these questions
when you have events
like this take place.
And we've still not solved it
today, I mean, in the industry.
GEROVITCH: So did they stick
to that asynchronous design
in the shuttle program?
PRESENTER 6: Did they
stick to the-- excuse me?
GEROVITCH: Asynchronous
executive--
PRESENTER 6: I think that
they had a mixed system.
PRESENTER: It was a hybrid.
Yeah.
PRESENTER 6: It was some
sort of a mixed system.
They had some hardware
constraints on their I/O
processors, and the
synchronization of I/O
with the computer that made it
impossible to have, I think,
a purely asynchronous executive.
So they had some real hardware
issues involved in it.
And we, and the company
that we formed after the--
we created a programming
system for shuttle,
in which we built into
the programming language
the concept of asynchronicity.
That is, that you could have
multiple jobs and priorities
and interrupts and
things like that.
And the shuttle people,
for the most part,
didn't want to use
those features that we
had put in the language.
We were very influenced
in the language
by the experience in
Apollo, and very influenced
by the executive that
Hal Laning had designed,
and the manner in which he
had designed that whole thing.
We were very influenced,
in the language design,
to take advantage
of those things,
of which they were,
I would say, used
to a minor extent in the
manner in which the shuttle was
put together.
GEROVITCH: Maybe we'd make a
little break for five minutes
while they're
changing the tape now.
PRESENTER 6: OK.
GEROVITCH: And then we'll
continue for about one hour.
Because we started at 10:00.
PRESENTER 6: That's fine.
PRESENTER: That's fine.
PRESENTER 4: All the
time on our Apollo,
we had just about no
contacts to the military.
The military has its
own-- were worrying
about military
satellites and so on.
But our paths just didn't cross.
I don't know if shuttle is where
they finally came together,
but not on Apollo.
There were a big difference
between the people
we dealt with in Houston
and most of NASA and Langley
and the old people, versus
Huntsville, Wernher Von
Braun and the German
gangs down there.
They did things a
little bit differently.
And so there was a lot
of difference of opinion.
I mean, they built things in
a certain way, which was very,
very solid, [? methodical. ?]
PRESENTER 6: With
all due respect
to Jim's time in
the service, I think
there was an actual disdain for
the military in this program.
I think that you were afraid
of the military getting
some sort of influence on
the program, in some fashion.
And you were very happy that
the program was completely open,
and it was open to the
public, and it was--
you could talk about it, and--
PRESENTER 5: Well, there
were certain aspects
that still had the stamp
of the military on them.
Some of those inertial
instruments and stuff
were still classified
documents, if I remember right,
at the beginning.
PRESENTER 6: Is that right?
PRESENTER 5: Trying
to get some data.
Because they sprang
from Polaris and things.
PRESENTER 7: Were the computer
instructions classified?
PRESENTER 5: Not
that I recall, no.
PRESENTER 2: The
only thing I remember
being classified
about the computer
was the oscillator frequency.
PRESENTER 7: Because
I wasn't able to get
a hold of the [? Block ?]
1 instructions because
of some reason.
I thought it had to do with
being classified, but--
when I first came to learn.
PRESENTER 1: I
think ossified is--
PRESENTER 7: Was it ossified?
PRESENTER 1: Ossified.
[LAUGHTER]
PRESENTER 7: Do you
remember that, Dan?
You weren't able to
give me-- or Al--
that you couldn't
give me a document
because it was classified.
PRESENTER 5: I don't
remember that exactly.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PRESENTER 5: I know there
were source documents that
were classified.
PRESENTER 7: So you
had to write down--
I can remember you had to
write down a few instructions
to say here they are.
PRESENTER 6: But didn't we
have safes in that building?
I remember-- I can
picture the safe.
PRESENTER 5: Yeah.
PRESENTER 6: I can't
remember what I kept in it.
PRESENTER 4: What was in there?
It was definitely
a classified area.
Yeah.
PRESENTER 7: Yeah.
PRESENTER 5: Having to
do with the inertial--
PRESENTER 6: I thought it
had to do with the rocket.
PRESENTER 4: I don't know.
PRESENTER 7: You can see how
much we were influenced by--
GEROVITCH: Did you have
to obtain any security
clearance or something?
PRESENTER 6: Yes.
We all had security clearances.
PRESENTER 7: Yeah.
PRESENTER 6: But I don't
know whether the security
clearance--
PRESENTER 4: Nothing we ever
wrote was classified, though.
PRESENTER 5: It was
[? unclassified. ?]
PRESENTER 6: My
security clearance
was initiated in the Polaris--
PRESENTER 2: That's
where it came from.
Yeah.
PRESENTER 6: I think it was kept
going from that [INAUDIBLE]..
PRESENTER 7: But then
I had to get one.
PRESENTER 6: Oh,
you had to get one.
PRESENTER 7: Yeah.
PRESENTER 5: Interesting.
I had one.
PRESENTER 7: Although, actually,
I had one in the Sage system,
so maybe mine was left over.
I don't know.
GEROVITCH: And so you
didn't have any sense
that the military
were interested at all
in innovations that
went on in your project?
PRESENTER 6: No.
PRESENTER 7: We never
thought in terms of--
PRESENTER 1: The
only military person
I can associate with
Apollo is General Phillips,
and he didn't exactly
come around looking over
our shoulder.
PRESENTER 4: No.
PRESENTER 6: I don't know.
I think that's a
little too strong.
I don't know that we knew
that they weren't interested.
They just were out of sight.
They just weren't--
PRESENTER 7: They
just weren't part of--
GEROVITCH: I think
they just thought
we were going to
totally flop, so why
did they want to talk to us?
[LAUGHTER]
PRESENTER 5: Yeah.
Going to the moon was
a political thing, not
a military thing.
So--
PRESENTER 7: Yeah.
PRESENTER 5: There
were no objectives
of the military involved in it.
They weren't going to the moon.
PRESENTER 6: Well,
there may have been,
but they didn't [INAUDIBLE].
PRESENTER 7: It was
an [? eagle ?] thing.
PRESENTER 5: Yeah.
PRESENTER 7: I mean--
PRESENTER 6: It might
have been an edict.
It might have been an edict
from the President, you know?
That this is an open
program, that this
is a big political
show for the world.
PRESENTER 7: Right.
PRESENTER 6: We're going to
have everything [? open, ?]
you know?
PRESENTER 7: Because Sputnik
happened, so we had to go and--
PRESENTER 6: Contrasted
with the Russians,
they were in the
middle of Siberia,
and nobody knows
what's going on.
And here, this is
completely open.
GEROVITCH: In Russia, there
was always kind of a rule
that if a significant invention
was made that might potentially
have military significance,
they were classify it,
even if it was done within
some open program, initially.
But this here doesn't seem
to be that kind of oversight,
in the sense of
military searching
for things that are going
on that might potentially
be important.
PRESENTER 6: Well,
there's a big danger
in that because the
military, it seemed to me,
and the people who were
in charge of security,
had a ever-expanding horizon.
I mean, you'd have
everything being classified
because you couldn't tell
whether this little gizmo might
have a military significance.
So after a while, you'd wind
up with almost everything.
GEROVITCH: That's what
the Russians [? wanted. ?]
PRESENTER 6: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
GEROVITCH: So I'm
getting a sense
that there was a
lot of interaction
[? in ?] small groups while
working on those programs.
Or did you have mostly one
program, one programmer?
Or several programmers
working on one program?
How kind of knowledge
about what--
PRESENTER 7: Maybe four or
five on each functional area.
PRESENTER 6: Well,
you had-- yeah.
You had different areas.
I mean, if somebody was
working a navigation module,
they probably did not
have too much contact
with some people who were
working in powered flight.
So they were worried about
star sightings and covariance
matrices, and
things having to do
with navigation computations.
And somebody else was
worried about auto pilots
and how they were going
to fire engines and so on.
And they were aware
of each other,
but there may not be very
strong interfaces between them.
And these two groups, I
would say they might be--
you might have a powered flight
group of maybe six people,
and you know, a navigation group
of some other number like that.
And you had people
who were testing,
and you had people who
were writing specs.
And so I'd say you had a
lot of programming groups.
And when you add it up,
you get to the numbers
we're talking about.
But each group was a
somewhat contained group.
PRESENTER 1: There was a
parallel group of analysis guys
that were writing back
programs all the time,
and testing algorithms
and so forth.
They weren't really writing
software for the [INAUDIBLE]
computer.
PRESENTER 5: Yeah, I was
going to make that comment.
Because programmer was
not a job description.
Some people programmed
and did analysis,
and some people
only did analysis.
Somebody did all their
work in [? Mac, ?]
this analytical programming
language we had.
I got the brunt of that
because I remember,
in trying to put this
first flight program--
of which I was the inaugural
rope mother-- together,
I had to interface
with these groups
and make their stuff meet
the stuff of the next group I
remember putting the launch
people stuff, which was just
plain analyzing dynamics and
finding out where we were,
to the powered flight
people, who steered the thing
and took over the
mission at that point.
Then it went into
this midcourse thing,
where some of these
star-sighting people,
who were wacko analysts--
I mean, I didn't
understand what--
I still, to this day, don't
really understand some of that.
That was a whole
different regime.
Because here, 10 minutes was
a short time to these guys.
Whereas one second was a lot
to the powered flight people.
And then, I survived going
through that midcourse stuff.
Got all their stuff straight.
Was able to, then, power up this
guy, who [? was ?] the entry.
He'd been working [INAUDIBLE].
And I remember the
first day at simulation,
knitted these two
phases together,
and we got a coordinated--
so these guys' program--
Dan and Ray's program,
and Fred and company,
and some of the
other-- and all my glue
that I had hung this thing
together with actually worked.
But there were a lot of
different programming styles
and conventions that you have
to straighten out, you know?
These guys expected
the delta V's in some--
we were giving it in the wrong--
you have to-- you know,
this kind of thing.
So putting these cells together
was an integration job.
We didn't integrate
at the beginning.
It was not a programming
exercise for the whole mission.
There were these
analytical groups,
some who did programming,
some who did different styles.
There were no standards.
All that received a lot more
discipline and method later.
PRESENTER 6: [INAUDIBLE]
[? model ?] that you had--
that we didn't have more
interface-type errors.
Because we did
have no standards.
We had no programming standards.
Each group, or each little
entity, would have a style.
I think, when we got
this project management,
I did try, to some extent,
to get some standardization,
but it was hard.
I think people used different
expressions for constants
in their programs.
PRESENTER 1: But don't
forget Don [? Boler ?]
and the stuff he did with ICDs.
If we hadn't had a function
like that, with all of its specs
from all of [? those ?] other
vendors, as well as our own,
we would have really
been up a creek.
And that was absolutely--
PRESENTER 5: Who was that?
PRESENTER 1: Don [? Boler. ?]
PRESENTER 6: Don Boler.
PRESENTER 5: Don Boler.
Big Don.
Another guy I remember, even
bigger, Peter [? Peck-- ?]
PRESENTER 1: Yeah,
he was a big guy.
PRESENTER 5: --who
instituted control
over revisions and stuff.
I don't know if that group
that you said that took over--
wasn't that Peter's group?
PRESENTER 4: Well, he
started it earlier,
[? when ?] he did it all along.
PRESENTER 5: But this
came out of nowhere.
He thought this needed to be
done, and he started doing it.
I mean, there was no "you are
the configuration manager."
PRESENTER 7: Oh,
Peter [? Peck. ?]
PRESENTER 5: Peter started
that kind of stuff.
He'd come and argue with you.
You couldn't put changes
in that, [INAUDIBLE]..
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
PRESENTER 5: Yes.
He was a very large person.
[LAUGHTER]
PRESENTER 7: You don't
want him to sit on you.
PRESENTER: I know what this is.
PRESENTER 5: But we invented
that in the course of the work.
PRESENTER 1: There certainly
were integration problems
outside our building.
And I think that our experiences
within the building--
and we were all within a
building which wasn't that big
of a building-- were
relatively well-controlled.
But some of the interface
problems we had that
were experienced between our
stuff and other people's stuff,
and between various
other people's stuff--
I remember, for example--
was it 501, Dan, or 502 where
there was an engine failure,
and the software-- it had
nothing to do with us--
shut down another
engine, thinking
that they were shutting down
the one that had failed.
And so it was down two
engines out of five.
PRESENTER 4: Right.
We ended up in orbit,
and they were supposed
to do a translunar injection.
But because of the
failure, and they
didn't have a [? S4B ?] left,
or whatever it was, we ended up,
instead of on a trajectory
headed towards a translunar,
we ended up either in orbit
or an elliptical thing.
So instead of doing a burn to
knock us out of a translunar
trajectory, we burned
first to put us in,
then we turned around
and knocked us out.
PRESENTER 1: That
was one example
of one of these
integration problems
that woke up a lot of people.
I think the accident
on the pad was probably
the single biggest disaster
that woke people up and stopped
the project for, what, a
year and a half or something.
Investigations were done,
and block tub was invented.
They hustled into place.
The mission that I
was involved with,
which was subsequently
called Apollo 5, which
we called Apollo 2-- or
didn't call Apollo 206,
it was just 206.
First flight of the LEM,
which is unmanned and--
PRESENTER 6: This is
the flight I think
I mentioned the last time.
Is this the one that only--
it was at the Cape,
and the engine shut off
in two seconds or four seconds?
PRESENTER 1: Well, I'll
mention a little bit
about what happened because
I think it was revealing.
We'd never flown a
Grumman spacecraft before,
and I'd never guided one.
We'd never flown a block
tube system before.
We'd never flown a
digital autopilot before.
So there was a lot of new stuff,
and its rope mother was new.
And we had a lot of veterans
and a lot of other people
that were new.
And our relations
with Grumman were
different than the relations
with North America.
PRESENTER 4: Were they?
[? Hoag ?] [? talked ?]
last time about it.
PRESENTER 1: It was just a
whole different ballgame.
And I, for one, had never had
any contact with the mission
control people, and didn't
have much as it was.
But I went down there to one
flight procedures meeting.
It was run by the
guy who was going
to be the flight director.
And let me not to
mention his name.
But it was a terrible
meeting, I thought.
The guy was so arrogant and
obnoxious that people just
stayed quiet who probably should
have asked questions or spoken
up.
But in the event
of the flight, we
had the first burn scheduled.
And although we'd
simulated it lots
of times, when the command
went to the engine,
unknown to me, as the
mission program guy
and as the simulation
guy, there was
a lot of pressurization
of tanks and stuff
that took place
between the fire signal
and when the engine
actually lit up.
And I had been told
by the guy that
wrote the descent
burn software, that it
had to have a very narrow
window on the start-up because
of something or other.
I don't remember what.
But we had a fairly
narrow window in there.
And it was-- the
timing of the interrupt
and so forth, it just missed
reaching the delta V threshold
by milliseconds, if I remember.
And so we shut it down.
The software shut it down.
And utter chaos took place
in mission control center.
Everybody was climbing
all over everybody
to find out what happened,
totally preventing anybody
from finding out what happened.
Because managers were
insisting on knowing
stuff that you didn't know yet.
And it was bad
procedure, and I don't
know if that continued
on other flights,
but it certainly
screwed up this one.
PRESENTER 6: Were
you in Houston then?
PRESENTER 1: Yeah.
PRESENTER 6: All right.
This is the--
PRESENTER 1: But let me go on.
PRESENTER 6: Go ahead.
I'm sorry.
PRESENTER 1: We
had put in there,
as a part of the
mission software, a very
clever and fairly
extensive ability
to reprogram all of these burns.
And when we-- through the
hierarchy of Jack Garmin,
up to the flight director--
told them that we could
easily reprogram this thing
and try it again,
the answer was,
it's no longer within
telemetry coverage.
Somehow, they had designed this
mission, unbeknownst to us,
in a way that there
was no possible way
to use this reprogramming
stuff if anything went wrong.
[? Of ?] course,
was the only purpose
for which this
reprogramming software
was in the flight computer.
But there was no
telemetry coverage
if the mission didn't
go exactly perfectly.
And of course, there was
no need to reprogram it
if that's what happened.
So here we were, out
of telemetry coverage.
And then, they decided to use
the LEM abort guidance system--
[? AGGS-- ?] to do
that burn, and drop
the thing without any knowledge
of the guidance software.
It took control away from
the guidance software,
gave it to the onboard
[? guy at the ?]
LEM abort guidance system,
which fired the descent stage,
separated and did an
ascent stage burn.
And then, they handed
the control back
to the guidance system.
Well, nobody had ever planned or
thought that that would happen.
And the guidance system on--
our guidance system
on the LEM knew
that it was in the
descent configuration.
By then, the descent
stage had been thrown off.
And so the digital autopilot
had this little sporty vehicle
when it thought it was
controlling this massive thing,
and so it was doing
horrible limit cycles
and burning fuel
like nobody ever saw.
And they said, what's going on?
Well, I knew right
away what was going on.
Nobody, of course,
had asked MIT anything
when all this was happening.
They just knew better
and took over, of course.
I thought they
didn't know better.
But I, again, sent
the information up
that if they do this heat soak
thing that we had put in there,
that the first thing it
did was to check agreement
between the bits that indicated
what stages were present
and the configuration the
guidance system thought.
And if it found a
mismatch, it would
correct the situation
for the guidance system,
and then pop out
of this program.
So it was a way to
get the thing back
in sync with one uplink command.
When this was made known
to the flight director,
he said, we can't
do that program.
We've never run it in
our practice simulations
here at mission control.
[LAUGHTER]
And here was this thing that
we'd spent a lot of time
putting in the-- it was the
second thing in the flight
software that couldn't,
or wouldn't, be used
by the mission control people.
Well, the result was not good,
and we took a lot of flak
for that.
I think a lot of it undeserved.
But I think it really shook up
the mission control people, who
realized that their
abilities to handle things
was much lower
than they thought.
And their ability to
understand and deal
with the possibilities of what
would go wrong in the flight
computer, and in the
system other within that,
was completely undeveloped.
And I think they went
through a lot of learning,
and made a lot of changes that
led to the success in things
like the lunar landing, where
something really unexpected
came up.
And there were people there
who were confident enough,
or foolish enough--
[LAUGHTER]
--to say, go, whatever it was.
But it worked.
But without some of these
blunders that happened,
I think there would have
been a much worse outcome,
or could've.
PRESENTER 6: Let me ask you--
did you-- did the clever
things that you had put in,
were they known to
the mission controls?
PRESENTER 1: They were
[? in the ?] software.
They were in the software.
They had tested all its--
no, our contacts knew
that they were in there.
It wasn't our job, and
we didn't have time
to do anything that
wasn't our job.
We didn't have time to do
things that were our job.
I was working 80 hours
a week during that time.
PRESENTER 6: Sure.
PRESENTER 1: [? Aaron ?] Cohen
kept saying, go down to Grumman
and talk to them.
When?
Who's going to do the
configuration control?
I would stay there till 8
or 9 o'clock every night,
looking at the
changes to the listing
to make sure that the
assembly was successful.
Usually, it was.
I didn't have time
to go to Grumman.
I would've stopped--
how many people were
working in putting restarts in?
But we ran out--
PRESENTER 6: But when
you were down there,
that was one of the
only launches I went to.
And I was at the
Cape at that time.
And when that happened, I was
telling the group here last
time, that there was a lot of
finger-pointing that occurred
on this narrow window
you were talking about,
as to whether this was a
programming error or whether--
we were programming
exactly what the engine--
we were programming that
to the characteristics
of the engine that were
given to us from Grumman.
And there was a lot
of finger-pointing
as to whose fault it was.
And of course, along
came Doc Draper,
who was down at the Cape.
He'd like to know
what was going on.
So there was this picture
of this madhouse room
with a listing this big,
opened up to page 179,
or whatever it is.
And somebody sticking
Doc Draper's nose
into these various
assembly language things,
trying to talk about how
this engine was cut off.
PRESENTER 1: Well, that
points out something else
that I didn't think of, but
I think is worth saying.
I don't know if 206 was the
first mission of this sort,
but it was a first--
it may have been--
where Houston had told us
that they, not we, were going
to be responsible for what
we call the erasable load,
which was the stuff
that was preloaded
into the erasable
memory before launch.
So the responsibility
for the erasable load
was ostensibly with the
guys down in Houston.
Well, that was fine.
But for the simulator, we
had to have a lot of stuff
preloaded into erasable memory.
And there was this piece of
code called Mr. Clean, which
would go clean out stuff and
preload all of these constants
that we thought would be fine
for the erasable to start with.
And people could override
those and so forth.
But that's what that
thing did, if I remember.
It was there for some reason.
I remember it was a
popular commercial
on the radio at the
time that happened
to fit in eight letters,
and so that's what it got.
[LAUGHTER]
But it turned out, Houston never
touched the erasable, at least
for 206.
And so the stuff that we had in
there for the simulator, which
always worked in the
simulator, and Grumman
ran the simulations,
and we never heard--
I never heard anything
from Grumman that
said something's funny there.
But there was another
one of these mismatches,
where we never saw
what Houston might
have done to the erasable load.
It turns out they
didn't do anything.
But there were these interface
gaps that weren't local,
but there were between
geographic locations, that
went wrong, and I think caused
people to shore up the defenses
a little bit on missions
that came later.
But without some
of those mishaps,
I don't know where
we would've come out.
But that was a tremendous
disappointment to all of us
that busted our
tails on the 206.
And it was never possible
to point a finger.
I could never point
a finger at anybody.
I remember exactly
where I was standing
when the person who was
responsible for the dips burn--
I'm not going to mention his
name, but everybody here,
I think, knows who I mean--
told me there were
restrictions on that thing.
And so the number came
directly from him.
I didn't make it up.
And so it wasn't something
that we did just crazy.
But mishaps helped us a lot.
The accident, of course,
took three lives.
It was way beyond our purview.
But had the biggest effect.
Because I think,
without that accident,
we never would have
made the schedule,
and maybe never would've
made the landing.
PRESENTER 5: Something
else I remember about it,
it was to [? have ?] [? flown ?]
the flight program 204?
PRESENTER 1: Yeah.
PRESENTER 5: That program,
which we were forced to release,
was just so lousy, so
[? chocked full ?] of bugs.
It would've killed them anyway.
That's my feeling.
It was so--
PRESENTER: Woof.
PRESENTER 5: It was
sort of a blessing,
if you can call it that,
that that was ditched
and was never used, and we
went into block [? tube. ?] But
PRESENTER 1: It's an example of
how-- and I mentioned before,
each program was supposed
to be an evolutionary step
from the one before.
PRESENTER 5: Yeah.
PRESENTER 1: This
one had a crew on it.
The one before it
had no crew on it.
If you don't think that
was utterly different,
it was utterly different.
PRESENTER 5: And I remember, we
had six weeks to turn it out.
PRESENTER 1: Yeah,
very short schedule.
And of course, nobody
wanted to be the one that
caused the schedule to slip.
PRESENTER 5: Yep.
PRESENTER 1: We were
confident Grumman
would make the schedule slip.
We just knew they'd
never make it.
Of course, they did, which
caught a lot of us by surprise.
A lot of good things
happened, too.
I remember, when we
ordered the first 360,
Lyndon Johnson had just ensured
that IBM got a sole-source
contract to supply four
[? 36075's ?] to the
[? manned ?] Spacecraft Center.
And all the other vendors were
just completely up in arms.
And IBM, who was the only bidder
that could do this, supposedly,
had to supply a fifth
computer because the four
computers didn't meet
the specs and so forth.
It was a horrible situation.
And I went to the
guy down there that I
had to go to say we
needed a faster machine,
and we want to put out a
request for a proposal.
And got approval to do that.
We got bids from at
least three vendors.
And I called him up
and I said, well,
we've done our
proposal evaluation.
We're ready to proceed.
Any problem with that?
And he said, no, not any at all.
He said, who is the
winner of your proposal?
I said, IBM.
He said, oh.
He said, we're going to need a
lot of justification for that.
So we spent about a
month writing down what
we thought they wanted to hear.
People's [? time-- ?] Cliff
[? Hyde ?] was a guy that
[? wants ?] to sort of
[? saying ?] why IBM was
the chosen vendor.
So there were a certain
amount of politics in there
that didn't have
anything to do with us.
But other funny things happened.
I don't know if this
is useful or not.
Houston wanted to have an
independent computer simulation
from the one we had,
as a cross-check.
And so they assigned somebody
to write a simulator--
and they wrote it in
Fortran, I think--
of not the computer,
but some other stuff.
And I had personally modified
our [? Mac ?] executive,
so that some things that we
needed to do could be done
by runtime software in the
[? Mac ?] executive that ran
at runtime for [? Mac, ?]
that involved stealing some
functions that I knew nobody, or
thought nobody would ever use.
We had hyperbolic cosecant
function in the language
that I didn't think
anybody had ever used.
And so if you put hyperbolic
cosecant of minus 1
in there or something, it would
type on the console typewriter
or something.
And I got a look at the listing
of their independent simulator
written in Fortran.
And right there, [INAUDIBLE]
hyperbolic cosecant of minus 1
to write on the console
of a machine that
wasn't even the one they used.
And certainly, not what you'd
call an independent simulation.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE] this code
directly into Fortran
without the slightest
idea of what it was doing.
But here we are, with
a real cross-check.
We did get there.
I was going to say--
I lost the thread.
Senior moment.
It happens almost
continually with me now.
After having gotten this first
IBM machine against all odds,
and getting it installed,
and stealing it from somebody
that we were doing
business with.
And George Miller called
them up and told them
they were going to have
to lose their machine.
And it got very ugly
because they got really--
this company got
really angry with us
for identifying them as
somebody who might give up
a machine and so forth.
It took us quite a long time
to get it in and installed.
And we were running lots
of simulations on there,
and a lot of other
lab stuff, as well,
when we realized we just
needed more simulation time
than there was on one
machine in one a week.
So I went to Chris
[? Craft ?] and said,
we've got to have
a second machine.
It was absolutely astonishing.
Within six weeks, that machine
was running in our place.
Before, it had taken
probably 10 months.
And he just was able
to make things happen
for us, and for everybody else
in the project, that really
gave it what it
needed to succeed.
And I think without influences
like Chris [? Craft, ?] both
inspirationally-- because
he really was a guy we all
respected and liked--
and without his clout, the
project would have not made it.
There were just lots of things
that happened to come together.
PRESENTER 6: By the way,
he's written a recent book.
Has anybody read that?
PRESENTER 4: I've
seen him on TV,
and heard him on the
radio talking about it,
but I haven't had a chance
to look at the book.
PRESENTER 6: It's supposed
to be pretty good.
PRESENTER 7: But on Apollo?
PRESENTER 6: Yeah, and the
space program and issues, and--
PRESENTER 4: Everything.
PRESENTER 6: Very frank.
PRESENTER 1: I also read,
in Jean [? Kranza's ?] book,
that the volume of
Tindall grams was actually
published and circulated.
I've never seen that, either.
PRESENTER 4: They have some here
because Malcolm sent his packet
to you guys, right?
I think he sent it--
GEROVITCH: To Sandy.
PRESENTER 4: Sandy.
To Sandy.
PRESENTER 1: Way
after [? words-- ?]
it must have been
'91 or so, I saw
Bill Tindall at
Intermetrics and urged him
to publish his Tindall grams.
And he maybe already had,
but he didn't say so.
He said, why would anybody
want to read that stuff?
And I tried to sell
him on the idea,
but he didn't further
do it, as far as I know.
But I did read that,
from the [? press, ?]
that they were
circulated around.
[INAUDIBLE]
Another guy, without which
things would have gone
far differently, and worse.
PRESENTER 4: Right.
Bill Tindall helps
solve so many--
especially at
Houston down there.
Drag them all together
and beat enough heads--
pound enough heads
together to get agreement.
It was amazing how he
did it without any--
just by dint of his personality.
I'm not sure he really was
the guy-- the boss of any
of those people.
But when he said
it, it happened.
PRESENTER 5: Well, I remember,
before Bill, the ill-fated Dr.
[? Joe ?] Shay.
Remember that--
PRESENTER 4: Poor Joe.
PRESENTER 5: [? FACI ?]
or whatever we had there.
PRESENTER 4: Joe got--
PRESENTER 5: He got the axe.
PRESENTER 4: Blamed for a lot of
things that weren't his fault,
I thought.
PRESENTER 5: But he had a
style about him in conducting.
You remember those [? FACIs-- ?]
first article configuration
inspection?
It was Joe [? Shay ?] sitting
like this [INAUDIBLE] red
[? socks ?] on his boots.
He didn't-- he was a
rather unassuming guy.
I was kind of fond of him,
and looked at him from afar.
Then he got-- he was
the scapegoat for all--
PRESENTER 6: You know, in the
later stages of the program,
we talked a lot
about the personnel
and the people at MIT, and
good people that we got,
and so on, and the closeness.
In the later stages
of the program,
it was the determination that
we didn't have enough personnel.
And that we needed to run this
more like an aerospace program,
you might say.
And so there was
actually an effort
to bring in
contractor personnel.
And I don't know how many were
brought in, but quite a few--
a lot.
And by and large, these
people were very good people.
And they were integrated
into our efforts,
but it was just
another example of how
something that began relatively
small and close started to get,
toward the end, look like
a lot of other programs,
where you brought in people
under different badges
and different
management, and so on.
And then you also faced--
tried to parcel
or proportion them
in intelligent
ways, either testing
or trying to create
tasks that they could
do that were self-contained.
But in many cases,
they were integrated
into groups that [INAUDIBLE]
IT personnel, as well.
I think that, by
and large, that we
did that fairly successfully.
PRESENTER 7: And in the
flight software group,
I think they were--
you couldn't even remember
that they were subcontractors.
PRESENTER 6: Right.
PRESENTER 7: [? You're ?]
told to [? sign ?] them.
PRESENTER 4: Yeah,
Joe [? Sapinaro, ?]
who ran that large team,
cracked the whip on all of--
PRESENTER 7: Yeah.
PRESENTER 1: It's been a
bunch of guys from CUC.
PRESENTER 4: Yeah.
PRESENTER 6: Yeah.
PRESENTER 4: Phyllis.
PRESENTER 1: And
I don't remember
how many from AC, but
if Jay Sampson hadn't
been in that group, we
would've languished.
PRESENTER 4: Right.
We did the 501 with
Jay and the gang.
Jay did most of it.
PRESENTER 1: Who?
PRESENTER 5:
[? Ronnie ?] Gilbert.
PRESENTER 1: Oh, yeah.
GEROVITCH: Was there
any interaction
between the instrumentation
lab and the rest of MIT
as a teaching institution?
Did undergrads or grad
students [INAUDIBLE]??
PRESENTER 7: We hired a
lot of people from MIT.
PRESENTER 4: Well, there
was close interaction
about the time Apollo started,
because it wasn't so big,
and it was closely tied
with the aero department.
And the instrumentation
lab was part of MIT then.
You remember the faculty
[? club ?] [? athletic, ?]
and so on.
Like Lincoln Lab--
I don't know, maybe
Lincoln Lab still is.
But then, at some point,
due to Vietnam protests,
the lab split off.
I don't remember--
early '70s or so--
PRESENTER 5: '69, I think.
PRESENTER 4: --when
that happened.
And became less connected with--
PRESENTER 6: Well,
there was connections.
There were students-- you always
had research assistants that
were around.
People like me,
who did that twice.
I went from employee to--
and then became a student
and got a master's, and then
became a student, got a PhD,
and so on.
But there were other students--
there were always students
around.
Some of them turned into
astronauts, like Buzz Aldrin
and, I think, Ed
Mitchell, and some others
that were in the aero
department at one time.
PRESENTER 1: Dave
Scott was another one.
PRESENTER 6: Who?
PRESENTER 1: Dave Scott.
PRESENTER 6: I think so.
PRESENTER 1: Yeah.
PRESENTER 6: These
turned out to be students
of Dick [? Batton, ?]
and they all
wanted to know something
about guidance and control.
And I think, probably, students
of [? Wally Vanderbilt ?]
as well.
So there was a
connection into it,
although I don't think
that the people--
any of the people, other
than these students
that I mentioned--
I don't think that the
employees thought of themselves,
in any way, as
academics of any kind.
They were working engineers in a
laboratory associated with MIT.
And there was some vague, let's
say, organizational connection
up above, that certain MIT
policies would flow down,
whether it was retirement
benefits or health benefits,
and other things
of that nature--
library cards and--
PRESENTER 7: Going
to the faculty club.
PRESENTER 6: Going to
the faculty club, things
of that nature that you had.
One big difference
in the laboratory,
as opposed to some other
laboratories, like--
I don't know.
I'm not sure about
the radiation lab,
but I know, with
respect to Lincoln Lab.
Lincoln, at that time,
was a line item laboratory
in the Air Force.
So they got-- the Air
Force had a budget,
and they said, here's the
budget for Lincoln laboratories.
And they did all their work
under this budget item.
And the instrumentation
laboratory
didn't have any budget
angel, in that sense,
and they had to scrounge around
and do their own marketing,
and find work and so on.
And of course, Draper got
this huge sole-source contract
to do Apollo, which
was magnificent.
But basically, the lab
was not a kept lab.
They had to do--
they had to get out there in the
world and find that business.
And that was a big distinction
between this laboratory
and some of the other MIT labs.
I think the thing that
Dan is referring to
is that, during the
Vietnam War, there
were tremendous student
gatherings on campus here,
and all kinds of protests.
I think I had just
left the lab, and I
can't remember what the
essence of what they
were protesting at the lab.
I think it was
ballistic missile--
PRESENTER 1: Defense contract.
PRESENTER 5: Yeah.
Just military and
defense contract.
It had no place in academia.
PRESENTER 1: No.
PRESENTER 6: So you had--
PRESENTER 2: [INAUDIBLE]
PRESENTER 6: You had the
instrumentation laboratories.
This whole section was
hollow, you might say.
But there were other
sections of the lab that
were doing inertial guidance
work for ballistic missiles
and so on.
And we heard stories
of them having
barriers across the doors,
and bolts, and this and that.
And pressure to divest the
laboratory from the school.
And eventually,
some accommodation
was made with respect to the
organizational structure.
PRESENTER 4: All of us
were in one building
right around the corner
here, in Cambridge Parkway.
We weren't over at main MIT.
We were down towards Lotus.
Lotus wasn't there then.
A bunch of warehouses.
PRESENTER 2: The
building's gone now, right?
PRESENTER 4: Yeah.
PRESENTER 1: The
building's gone.
PRESENTER 7: Right next to
the hotel, what's that hotel?
PRESENTER 4: Sonesta.
PRESENTER 7: Sonesta.
PRESENTER 6: Well, that
was a couple of buildings
further down.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PRESENTER 7: Was that
what it was called?
PRESENTER 1: Before
it was the Sonesta.
PRESENTER 6: Of course,
Apollo didn't start in there.
We sort of gathered
into that building.
We started in other places.
The lab had--
I don't know.
That was W6, right?
No, that was 7.
W6 was way down Vassar Street.
And then, there was
1, 2, 3, 4, and 5.
And you had a garage, and
you had an old shoe polish
building, and so on.
And Apollo began in
these other buildings,
with various groups
of a few people
here and a few people
there, and so on.
And I can't remember
the exact date
when everybody was gathered.
PRESENTER 4: I don't know.
We had the big computers down
there in the first floor,
and Dick [? Batten ?]
in the corner.
And all of us--
PRESENTER 6: But I know Dick--
when I went to work for Dick,
he was in W1, near that
elevator shaft that was in W1.
And so--
PRESENTER 1: Yeah.
On the fourth floor.
PRESENTER 6: Yeah.
So it must have been--
PRESENTER 5: Where the 650 was?
PRESENTER 1: About '62, we had--
PRESENTER 6: Yeah,
it must've been 1962
or so, that everybody
was gathered and brought
into this one building.
And they had things
on the roof, too.
Didn't you have a
sextant and something
on the roof of this building
that did star sightings?
PRESENTER 4: When we all
moved to the second floors,
when you had the project
organization and all of that,
we took over all
that second floor.
PRESENTER 6: But I thought that
either [? Nevins, ?] or John
[? Dolan, ?] or somebody
had optical equipment.
PRESENTER 1: It seemed to me
that was down in [? 6. ?] 224
[INAUDIBLE] Street.
PRESENTER 4: A lot
of it was, but they
had the thing on
the roof that you
can look at the-- they had
that thing you sat up there,
Doc Draper's toy.
PRESENTER 6: Yeah.
Yeah.
PRESENTER 4: Anyway,
it was quite a time
in there starting
in the early '60s,
and escalated as you got closer
and closer to each flight.
And I mean, Alex did
the first one, 201.
I don't remember
the sequences after.
The first few were all unmanned,
and I don't even remember--
PRESENTER 5: Yeah,
201 was unguided.
I think 202 was the first
[? HEC-guided ?] [INAUDIBLE]..
PRESENTER 4: 202, I mean.
Right.
201 was just open-ended.
GEROVITCH: Just let me ask you
the last question, probably.
But did you have any
international contacts?
Did you go abroad
t Europe, whatever?
Did you have any contacts
with foreign [? venues? ?] Was
anybody interested from
abroad in what you were doing?
PRESENTER 6: I'm sure
there was great interest,
but I can't recall--
it wasn't like space lab.
I did some work on
space lab, where
you had a real international
group that you were--
PRESENTER 4: Nobody in the
world was doing much yet,
and so it all pretty early.
There were individuals
interested,
but there wasn't any
institutional interest.
PRESENTER 5: There was
huge popular interest.
PRESENTER 4: Right.
PRESENTER 7: I presented
a paper in Paris
at a conference on a
theory that had come out
of the Apollo project.
It was part of the--
part of our organization
sent us there.
So in that way--
but it wasn't really
what we did in Apollo.
It was what came
as a result of it.
GEROVITCH: Were they interested?
PRESENTER 7: Very interested.
I just can't-- my
mind can't remember--
PRESENTER 5: That was about
the mid-'70s, though, right?
PRESENTER 7: You
know, early '70s.
PRESENTER 5: Early '70s.
But it was still part
of the Apollo group.
The Colloquium
Program [INAUDIBLE]
colloquium or
something, in Paris.
Mostly academics.
But yeah, there was
a lot of interest.
But it was mostly academics,
not application types.
PRESENTER 4: No, during
Apollo, most of our trips
were to Houston,
or for those of us
that dealt with Rockwell,
out to Rockwell.
It was all the
business meetings.
PRESENTER 6: But some of us
were very shocked when we--
I was shocked when I first
made a trip to North America.
And we had--
I don't know-- you have the
Cambridge scene here, you know?
Everybody has his own office,
and everything's sort of quiet.
And you look out the window.
You might see the river--
PRESENTER 7: And watch
the planes take off.
PRESENTER 6: Yeah, watch
PRESENTER 7: From my office,
that was my favorite thing.
PRESENTER 6: And then you
made these business trips out
to Rockwell, to North America.
PRESENTER 4: North American--
PRESENTER 6: What you
were faced with was
this three-block-long, open
hangar with God knows how
many people in that hangar.
And telephones
ringing and noise--
PRESENTER 5: The [INAUDIBLE]
edge of the building was lost
in the smoke--
PRESENTER 6: Right.
PRESENTER 5: [INAUDIBLE]
PRESENTER 6: The contrast--
you wondered how anybody
got any work done.
I mean, the contrast
between what
we used to think of as
the aerospace industry,
and the norm of
how people worked
in this aerospace industry
versus the norm of what we were
doing at MIT was night and day.
It was just a different world.
PRESENTER: Right.
PRESENTER 4: There
were metal vendors,
and they wanted to build 10,000
more airplanes if we told them
how.
PRESENTER 7: Our offices looked
like graduate students' offices
at MIT.
You walked in there--
I came from the
meteorology department,
and I felt like it was part
of the same environment.
It was not like a big
corporation outside of MIT.
PRESENTER 1: It was interesting,
in the early years, to me,
to find that MIT people--
we were never
instrumentation lab people.
We were always MIT people,
for whatever reason.
Although we had this local
environment of our own,
when we went out
to North America,
we found that we were
the communication
means between parts
of North America
that we interfaced with that
didn't talk to each other.
And often, we were the
ones that told them things
that their own management,
perhaps, should have told them.
But they were
really glad to know.
And we were served a very
useful, if inadvertent,
function that way.
PRESENTER 7: That's
interesting that you
say that because the glue
that Alex was talking about,
when we put together the
different powered flight
and navigation
and everything, we
found that we were
a communication
vehicle [? that ?]
the entire mission
software for the
different groups
that were being
interfaced, as well.
And that's how we
learned about--
we didn't really know what
was inside the-- or at least,
I was less familiar than
you-- inside the black boxes.
But we really knew how
they all tied together.
PRESENTER 4: One more thing you
probably should say about this.
Working at the
lab, which was MIT,
we were in a very
privileged position.
We got to see and talk to not
only all astronauts, everybody
at NASA, all over the place.
I mean, Wernher Von Braun
would come and visit.
And I remember giving him
lectures on what we were doing,
and so forth.
All those people,
we got to talk to
as a small, elite organization.
And when the flights were going
off-- the Apollo flights--
we were tied in very closely
on those headsets and boxes.
I can remember one flight--
I don't remember what and who
I was talking with in Houston.
Might have been Jack Garmin.
I said-- it was a problem
we had, and I said,
I think we need
an erasable dump.
Will you get one?
Within 30 seconds on the
main [? cap ?] commander--
PRESENTER 5: [? Capcom. ?]
PRESENTER 4: [? Capcom-- ?]
whatever-- to the astronauts.
MIT wants a dump.
Will you do it?
Something or other.
And it was always, MIT
wants this and that.
And so I felt
anything we did was
going to get there
and back very quickly.
That might have been
the time we're worried
about erasable being messed up.
PRESENTER 6: I also thought
some people attributed
a pedestal standing
to us that maybe, I
don't think we really deserved.
But--
PRESENTER 1: Oh, yeah.
PRESENTER 6: There was one
thing that happened, though,
that I still vividly recall.
It was near the end of the--
there was a landing on the
moon, and it was successful,
and they were--
the program-- it either was--
yeah, it was just
after that landing,
or it could have
been just before.
But we used to go to these
dinners at [? Lockovers. ?]
And I don't know how many I went
to, maybe four or something.
And Draper was very
expansive about this,
and he'd want to get
all these people there,
and he'd always have
some astronauts in there
because that was kind of fun.
And so I remember
this dinner, and I
was sitting next to
Frank [? Borman, ?]
and we were eating dinner.
And Frank Borman-- somewhere
in the conversation,
he felt that the people at
MIT-- we were all geniuses,
and we were all just these
almost like everybody
was a guru, and
everybody was a genius.
Then he said to me something
like, you guys at MIT,
you ought to get out
of this program now.
He said, this program
is nothing but--
it's going to be
just grinding it out.
He said, there's not going to
be anything more of interest.
There's nothing more
that you guys can do.
You ought to go off and do
something bigger and more
interesting than Apollo.
And I thought that
was interesting.
[LAUGHTER]
PRESENTER 4: So we
followed Frank [? Borman ?]
into Eastern Airlines.
[LAUGHTER]
PRESENTER 6: That's
exactly right.
GEROVITCH: All right.
PRESENTER 4: Yeah, we
did have a good position.
But also, there were so
many of the astronauts that
had previous connections
at MIT that we
weren't poked fun at too much.
We had some inside tracks.
PRESENTER 6: I might tell
you, just as a closing comment
for me, that Dick [? Batten ?]
asked me, last year,
to be a guest lecturer
at one of his sessions.
He runs a freshman
seminar on Apollo.
And he has these kids,
and kids come in.
And last year, he
had Harrison Schmidt.
Is that his name?
The astronaut.
And he had a number
of other people.
And I was there.
He's trying to get Don
[? Isles ?] to come in.
And it's really remarkable.
I only did it once.
And so what you do
is you're talking
to these kids, who are
about 18 years old,
and they really know
almost nothing--
zero.
I mean, whatever
they know, they know
from television or
cartoons, or maybe they
read something or other.
They know nothing.
But it is interesting,
the level of interest
that they have in the program.
And usually, a certain
percentage of them,
like four out of eight,
or five out of 10,
all have-- they all
want to be astronauts.
That's one of the
things that drives them.
Because you wonder why this
person, as a freshman, takes
this freshman seminar with
Dick [? Batten ?] on Apollo,
from 30 years ago.
But it is interesting.
Of course, Dick loves it.
And I did bring
in some artifacts.
This is a program listing.
This is a this, this is a that.
And most of it is just
getting up to a blackboard,
and drawing a few stick
figures, and telling them
a little bit about how we got
to the moon, and something
about the computer.
And each person has
something else to say.
Of course, I'm sure that
Harrison Schmidt gave them
the whole astronaut viewpoint.
It really is remarkable
for these kids
to have this connection,
though Dick [? Batten, ?]
to this world.
Because it's something
that very few people--
very few high school
students, or very few freshman
in college--
could have an opening to.
And to have these individuals
appear in front of them.
And Dick just loves it.
PRESENTER 5: This is something
I felt coming from Europe.
I've got friends
and relatives there.
Incredible intensity,
that interest
in Apollo, what happened.
I often feel like,
since I was in it,
I haven't done my
bit in satisfying
some of the yearning
for information,
and contact with
this glamorous world.
And that's just sort
of a popular reaction.
It's nothing to do with
military, academia,
or business or anything.
The men in the street view the
American Apollo program as just
an incredible achievement.
PRESENTER 6: If it
ever really happened.
PRESENTER 5: Indeed.
[LAUGHTER]
Is this true?
Yeah, people who weren't
even alive then still--
GEROVITCH: Yeah, we hope
that the website that we're
working on would--
one of its functions
would be to provide a
window into the history
of that program for students,
general audience who
might be interested in that.
[INAUDIBLE] both the
basis in documents,
but also a human subject
perspective on this event.
I wish to thank
you all very much.
It's been very, very--
PRESENTER 1: Your job is going
to be a severe one, in terms
of getting young people
now interested in things
that, by comparison,
with today's technology,
are so ancient and so primitive.
Why would anybody want
to look back at stuff
from a machine that had a 3-bit
op code and 12-bit address?
I just bought the Microsoft
flight simulator 2000,
and it says, you need to have
635 megabytes of disk space
available.
[LAUGHTER]
Good heavens.
PRESENTER 4: Wait until you
see the operating system that
comes out this fall.
PRESENTER 1: If this is what
the kids are dealing with,
why would they care
about a 36K word machine?
And the problems
that went with it,
that are just so completely
removed from today's problems.
PRESENTER 5: But I think
this could be a lesson--
PRESENTER 1: It can be knitted
into today, but you have--
that's a challenge for--
PRESENTER 7: I
would like to make
a comment about your comm--
along with your comment.
I think that, in looking around
at software problems today,
they still have
the same problems
that they had yesterday.
And I think many of the
things that we learned,
and that evolved--
lessons learned could
still be learned today.
The hardware is different,
but I think software, in fact,
is worse in many ways now.
It's done in a more primitive
way now than it was back then.
PRESENTER 5: Because the
resources are limitless,
people just don't try--
PRESENTER 7: So I think
we could go back and learn
a lot from what has
evolved from that.
So if we can't, then some
of us are in trouble.
GEROVITCH: Right, right.
So look at history not as
just progression of machines
getting bigger and
better, but also
the evolution of human skill.
PRESENTER 7: Of how you think.
GEROVITCH: Right, right.
PRESENTER 7: And
model and design.
Exactly.
GEROVITCH: And some of
those skills in the '60s
might have been very valuable
that is not really in use now.
PRESENTER 7:
Sometimes, we go back
to the very foundations,
the very core,
and learn from what we
might have thrown away.
PRESENTER 6: The other
thing is that people are--
even though they can hold a
handheld GPS in their hand,
they're still
interested in how people
did things with a sextant and
a watch, or not even a watch.
PRESENTER 7: Or a [? disky. ?]
PRESENTER 6: Or a [? disky. ?]
PRESENTER 7: Which I
sometimes call it by mistake.
[LAUGHTER]
GEROVITCH: Maybe we
should have a simulator
for [? disky ?] on the website
where they can actually press--
PRESENTER 7: Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PRESENTER 7: Oh, definitely.
PRESENTER 6: That'd be great.
GEROVITCH: You think so?
PRESENTER 7: Yes.
That would be great.
GEROVITCH: Then you can
call up all the programs
and get [? Jim's ?]
simulator going again.
PRESENTER 7: [INAUDIBLE]
GEROVITCH: Right.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PRESENTER 7: Yeah.
Priority alarms.
PRESENTER 6: You can have
your verbs and nouns.
PRESENTER 7: Yeah.
GEROVITCH: All right.
Thank you very much.
PRESENTER 7: Thanks.
GEROVITCH: I will be in touch.
As soon as we have
a transcript, I
will send it to all of you
for corrections and details
and all of that.
PRESENTER 1: I'd appreciate
a copy of the transcript
from the prior meeting,
so I can know--
GEROVITCH: All right.
Sure.
PRESENTER 6: That hasn't
been distributed yet, has it?
PRESENTER 7: None
of us have it yet.
PRESENTER 1: No, but--
but you know--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]